ओके सो आई थिंक वी आर लाइव नाउ
अ वी आर लाइव कैन यू हियर मी कैन यू सी मी
गाइस प्लीज मुझे बता दीजिए कि ऑडियो
वीडियो सब कुछ सही है जल्दी से बता दीजिए
जल्दी से फटाफट बता दीजिए ताकि मुझे पता
चल
जाए हेलो हेलो हेलो हेलो विक्रम हेलो यूडी
टेक हेलो नौ सखिया हेलो सलमान गुड इवनिंग
सबको गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग सबको आई एम
गुड गुड गुड गुड गुड नास किया ब्रदर अ
हेलो
गुलफाम हेलो
निमेशे देते हैं पहले जल्दी से जो लोग
नहीं आए हैं प्लीज ग्रुप में बता दीजिए
उनको जो हमारी बग हंटिंग की बग हंटर वाली
ग्रुप है
ऐसे ही जैसे पहले मिलते थे सीजन टू
स्टार्ट हो चुका है हमारे बग बाउंट फ्री अ
क्लासेस का फ्री बट क्वालिटी क्लासेस का
एंड सीजन टू में हम बहुत और भी धमाके करने
वाले हैं सीजन टू सीजन वन से बेटर होगा
बोरिंग नहीं होगा एंड सीजन टू में हम लाइव
हंटिंग पे बहुत ज्यादा फोकस करने वाले हैं
तो हम लाइव हंटिंग की सीरीज भी स्टार्ट
करने वाले हैं यानी कि वी विल बी डूइंग
लाइव बग बाउंट हंटिंग एंड लाइव में कुछ
मिला तो मिला अच्छी बात है अदर वाइज वी
विल जस्ट कीप ट्रा ट्रा कीप ट्राइट काइंड
ऑफ वनरे बिलिटी डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ
अप्रोचेबल तो बाकी लोगों को यहां पर आ
जाने देते हैं देन वल बी स्टार्टिंग
राइट आई एम गुड गुड आई एम गुड
ब्रदर या वी आर मीटिंग सो आफ्टर सो लंग
राइट सर आपका ऑफलाइन सेंटर कब ओपन होगा
जल्दी आपको उसकी इंफॉर्मेशन जो है वो मिल
जाएगी ठीक है तो जल्दी जाएगी नो इशू जल्दी
मिल जाएगी बिल्कुल मिलेगी आई
थिंक आप लोगों को ऑडियो वीडियो में कोई
इशू तो नहीं आ रही है एक बार बता दीजिए
मुझे एक बार क्योंकि यहां पे एक मेरे को
भी चेक कर लेने
दीजिए आई थिंक सही
है या आई थिंक इट्स
गुड ठीक
है ठीक है तो मैंने चेक कर लिया है
एवरीथिंग इज फाइन
चलिए बढ़िया बात है चलिए ऑलमोस्ट 50
स्टूडेंट्स है य काफी और स्टूडेंट्स को
मैं एक्सपेक्ट कर रहा हूं यहां पे एनफ
सर्विस एक्सप्लो हां जी यह बग बाउंट कोर्स
में कितनी वीडियोस आनी है अभी आएंगी 50
प्लस और आएंगी एंड अभी बहुत कुछ होने वाला
है तो सबसे पहले या तो फर्स्ट एंड फॉमस
थिंग अ वेरी वेरी हैप्पी रिपब्लिक डे टू
एवरी बडी रिपब्लिक डे की शुभकामनाएं आप
सबको तो यहां पे हम शुरू करें उसके पहले
जो है मैं आपको बता देता हूं कि यह जो है
linked-list इसके बारे में बहुत डिटेल में
वीडियो आएगी और आपको बताया जाएगा क्या
एगजैक्टली है ओंट इंडिया अब इसको भी फॉलो
अप कर सकते हैं देन यहां पे द इंफोसेक
डायरी नक्स के अंदर ही स्टार्ट किया हुआ
है एक और चैप्टर जिसके बारे में भी डिटेल
आएंगी आने वाले टाइम में इसको भी आप फॉलो
कर सकते हैं देन यहां पे गाइज आप
whatsapp2 से भी ज्यादा लोगों ने हमें
फॉलो कर रखा है जितने भी क्लासेस के
रिगार्डिंग अपडेट्स हैं बग बाउंट की
क्लासेस हो दूसरी से जो सारी अपडेट्स आपको
इस
whatsapp2 आप
आप देख सकते हैं डीसी जेएसपी वन ऑफ द
हमारा मोस्ट पॉपुलर अ कोर्स जो है वो भी
आपको यहां पे मिल जाता है तो आप इसको भी
जो है आप यहां से इनरोल कर सकते हैं देन
हमारी ये
youtube4 यू विल अ सी तो आपको समझ में
आएगा कि हमें हम क्या कर चुके हैं अभी तक
हमारा यह 50th 50 वां वीडियो है बग
बाउंटियस
की जो को क्वालिटी ट्रेनिंग आपको मिली अभी
तक उसमें हाफ सेंचुरी लगा दिया है आज के
इस क्लास के साथ ही तो कांग्रेचुलेशन टू
एवरी बडी आउट देयर अलोंग विद दिस जर्नी जो
हमारी जर्नी में थे हमारे साथ थे उन सबको
भी बहुत-बहुत बधाइयां एंड आप सब ने इतना
सपोर्ट इतना प्यार दिया है तभी जाके यह
सीरीज इतना पॉपुलर हुआ है कि आज इंडियन
कम्युनिटी इनफैक्ट इंडिया के बाहर जो
दूसरे कंट्रीज के बहुत सारे स्टूडेंट्स
हैं वो इस पर्टिकुलर बग 20 के सीरीज पे
डिपेंड करते हैं अपनी कंसेप्ट को एंड अपने
स्किल्स को एनहांस करने के लिए बहुत सारे
लोग यहां पे इन सीरीज के वीडियोस पे
रिटर्न व्यूवर्स हैं रिटर्न व्यूअर जो
हमें एनालिटिक्स से पता चलता है यानी कि
अगर आपने पहले देख रखा है वापस से आप
रिटर्न होके देखते हैं तो हमारे जो बहुत
सारे जो वो परसेंटेज है नाना वो बहुत हाई
है रिटर्न व्यूवर्स का क्योंकि उनको
कंसेप्ट देखना होता है समझना होता है जब
भी कोई कांसेप्ट समझ में नहीं आता वो बग
बाउंडी के इन क्लासेस के वीडियोस के ऊपर आ
जाते हैं इसके साथ ही साथ हम यहां पे आपको
फ्री एथिकल हैकिंग की क्लासेस भी प्रोवाइड
कर रहे हैं डीई एई हमारी जो सीरीज है उसके
थ्रू तो इसमें भी 23 क्लासेस हो चुकी हैं
आपको इस सीरीज को बिल्कुल फॉलो करना चाहिए
यू विल लव द कंटेंट एंड जितना इन डेप्थ
आपको जितनी चीजें बताई जाती हैं तो आपको
कहीं जाने की जरूरत आपको नहीं पड़ेगी इस
बात की गारंटी मैं आपको प्रोवाइड करता हूं
सबसे बड़ी चीज यह है कि बग बाउंट सीरीज
में जब आप आएंगे यहां पे प्लेलिस्ट में तो
प्लेलिस्ट में आपको यहां पे बग बाउंट की
प्लेलिस्ट दिख जाएगी ये बग बाउंट फ्री
ट्रेनिंग जब आप वू फुल प्लेलिस्ट करेंगे
तो यहां आप देखेंगे कि हमारा जो पहला
क्लास था इसका उसपे 150 के प्लस 150000 से
भी ज्यादा जो व्यूवर्स ने इन्हें देखा है
लर्नर्स ने इन्हें देखा है दूसरे वीडियो
पे हमने 50000 से भी ज्यादा लर्नर्स इस पे
आके देख चुके हैं ऐसे बहुत सारी जो
वीडियोस है वो काफी पॉपुलर हो चुकी है तो
आप अपने दोस्तों के बीच ये शेयर कर सकते
हैं प्लेलिस्ट को बग बाउंट सीरीज के बारे
में बता सकते हैं जिनको बग बाउंट में काफी
इंटरेस्ट है एंड वो एक्चुअली सीखना चाहते
हैं तो चलिए आज की जो क्लास है उसको हम
स्टार्ट करते हैं बट स्टार्ट करने से पहले
मैं आपको कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट चीजें बताना
चाहता हूं उसको जरूर आप ध्यान में रखिएगा
आज का जो टॉपिक है वो है जेडब्ल्यू अटैक
जेसन वेब टोकन अटैक जिसके बारे में हम
जानना चाहते हैं बेसिकली इसको हम जेसन वेब
सिगनेचर्स बोलते हैं जनरली बट इसको हम
जेडब्ल्यू t एज अ पॉपुलर क्वाइट पॉपुलर
टर्म यूज़ होने लगा है हमारा तो जेडब्ल्यू
t को हम कंसीडर करके चलेंगे अब यह जो है
यह एक एडवांस टॉपिक है एडवांस टॉपिक है
मतलब कि कि इसके अंदर बहुत सारी चीजें आती
हैं बट हम उसको बहुत ही धीरे-धीरे प्यार
से पढ़ के चलेंगे एंड इसकी एक और पार्ट
आएगी आज की सेशन में मैं आपको पूरा
जेडब्ल्यू अटैक सब कुछ ए टू जेड हैंड्स ऑन
प्रैक्टिकल सब कुछ आपको दिखाने वाला हूं
बताने वाला हूं कि कैसे एज एन एथिकल हैकर
आपको इस वलने बिलिटी के बारे में पता होना
चाहिए और किस तरीके से इस वलने बिलिटी को
आप वेब एप्लीकेशंस के अंदर में फाइंड कर
सकते हैं उसके बाद दूसरा जो पार्ट होगा
उसमें हम इस पे लाइव जो हंटिंग है वो भी
करेंगे एंड अदर थिंग्स जो और भी चीजें
रहेंगी वो भी हम देखेंगे तो आज के इस
शानदार प्रैक्टिकल सेशन के लिए तैयार हो
जाइए सारी डिस्ट्रक्शंस को दूर कीजिए एंड
कुछ यहां पर आपको जो सीखने को मिल रहा है
उसको सीख के जाइएगा तो सबसे पहले यहां पे
मैं आप सबसे पूछना चाहता हूं आर यू ऑल
रेडी फॉर टुडे सेशन एवरी बडी रेडी फॉर
टुडे सेशन आर यू ऑल रेडी पहले मुझे बता
दीजिए जस्ट लेट मी नो इफ यू आर रेडी वी
विल बी स्टार्टिंग राइट
यस यस यस रेडी रेडी रेडी रेडी क्या बात है
आपकी जोश कम तो नहीं हो गई है ना इतने
दिनों में जोश कम तो नहीं हो गई अब जोश कम
हो गई होगी तो मैं तो कुछ नहीं कर सकता
भैया लिटरली आई कांट डू एनीथिंग अगर जोश
कम हो गई होगी तो नहीं होना चाहिए आपका
जोश कम फ्री में ऐसा कंटेंट कोई डिलीवर
नहीं करता है ठोक के लिख के गारंटी ऑन
पेपर दे सकता हूं मैं बग माउंटी की तो
स्पेशली नहीं कराता है कोई एंड वो भी फ्री
में ऐसा कुछ जो आके कोई बोल दे कि अरे यार
इसमें तो गड़बड़ी है नहीं यह तो क्वालिटी
नहीं है इसमें तो हम देते हैं आपको हम
बिल्कुल एब्सलूट फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट
चलिए जोश हाई है बहुत अच्छी बात है तो आज
का यह टॉपिक बिल्कुल इंडिपेंडेंट टॉपिक है
तो अगर आपने पहले की क्लासेस नहीं भी करी
है बाय चांस आप आ गए हो आज की क्लास में
तो भी आप इस क्लास को देख सकते हैं
बिल्कुल समझ में आएगी एंड अच्छे से आपके
समझ में आएगी ठीक है चलिए जेसन वेब टोकन
अटैक को समझने से पहले हमको इसका थोड़ा सा
ओवरव्यू जानना पड़ेगा कि जेसन वेब टोकेंस
एक्चुअली होते क्या है यह जे डब्ल्यूटीओ
क्या है ठीक है तो यहां पे जे
डब्ल्यूटीए टोकन अ कंपैक्ट एंड सेल्फ
कंटेंट मेथड सेल्फ कंटेंट मेथड फॉर
सिक्योर ट्रांसमिटिंग इंफॉर्मेशन बिटवीन
पार्टीज एज अ जेशन ऑब्जेक्ट ठीक है दो
पार्टीज के बीच में यहां पर बात हो रही है
दो
डिवाइसेसपोर्ट
को कोई इंफॉर्मेशन को ट्रांसमिट करना हो
एज अ जेशन ऑब्जेक्ट तो उसको को जो है हम
बोलते हैं जेसन वेब टोकन जो कि एक सेल्फ
कंटेंट मेथड है सेल्फ कंटेंट मेथड है
जिसके थ्रू उस इंफॉर्मेशन को पास किया
जाता है जेसन स्ट्रक्चर में ठीक है अब
यहां पे इट इज वाइडल यूज्ड इन ऑथेंटिकेशन
एंड ऑथराइजेशन प्रोसेस अब इसकी वैल्यू
क्यों बढ़ जाती है ये एक हाई सीवियरिंग
वनबिल के अंदर कंसीडर किया जा सकता है
डिपेंड करता है कि किस तरह के
क्लेम्म मेंशन जो है उस ज ऑन वेब टोकन के
अंदर एज अ पेलोड जा रही है अब क्या है मैं
आपको सब कुछ समझाऊ सब आपको क्लियर हो
जाएगा एंड ये एक एडवांस टॉपिक है मैं आपको
लिटरली बता देता हूं जब हम वेब सिक्योरिटी
एकेडमी पे जाएंगे एंड यहां हम ऑल टॉपिक्स
पे जाते हैं ठीक है ऑल टॉपिक्स पे जाते
हैं पहले वेब सिक्योरिटी अकेडमी पे तो
आपको पहले सर्वर साइड टॉपिक्स मिलेंगे ठीक
है तो इसमें आपको अलग-अलग टॉपिक्स मिल
जाएंगे देन आपको क्लाइंट साइड टॉपिक्स
मिलेंगे वनबिल कीज आपको अलग-अलग टॉपिक्स
मिलल जाएंगे देन आपका एक आता है एडवांस
टॉपिक्स इसके अंदर आपको जेडब्ल्यू t अटैक
टॉपिक मिलेगा तो इट्स अ एडवांस टॉपिक जो
कि हम डील कर रहे हैं लेकिन हम इसको एकदम
इजी बना देंगे इतना इजी बना देंगे कि आपको
लगेगा कि अरे यह कौन सा एडवांस टॉपिक है
ये तो और भी इजी है बाकी कई सारी वनबिल से
इजी है इनफैक्ट तो ध्यान दीजिएगा समझ में
आ जाएगा गारंटी मेरी है ठीक है चलिए अब
देखिए इट इज वाइड यूज्ड इन ऑथेंटिकेशन एंड
ऑथराइजेशन प्रोसेस अब ये ऑथेंटिकेशन एंड
ऑथराइजेशन में जो यूज होता है तो इसकी
वैल्यू बढ़ जाती है यानी कि यूजर के
ऑथेंटिकेशन
यूजर के ऑथराइजेशन में इसकी बहुत बड़ी रोल
है एंड वहीं पे आ जाती है इसकी इंपॉर्टेंस
जो इसको हाईली इंपॉर्टेंट एक वनबिल बना
देती है एक हाई सीवियरिंग की व एबिलिटी
बना देती है कि उस पर्टिकुलर
पेलोड में वो इंफॉर्मेशन क्या इंफॉर्मेशन
जा रही है उस परे डिपेंड करता है इसकी
सीवियरिंग के कि क्या किस तरह का सीवियर
ये पर्टिकुलर जो है ये अटैक हो सकता है
जेडटी इज साइंड एंड ऑप्शनली इनक्रिप्टेड
टू इंश्योर डेटा इंटीग्रिटी एंड
कॉन्फिडेंशियल्टी तो यहां पे सीआईए ट्राइड
का कॉन्फिडेंशियल्टी एंड इंटीग्रिटी जो
चीज है यह यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं
सेफगार्ड हो रही है एंड इसको साइन किया
जाता है एंड ऑप्शनली इंक्रिप्ट भी कर दिया
जाता है अब नॉर्मल जो अ आपके जो ये साइंड
अ होते हैं बेसिकली जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन होती
है जो भी चीज होती है वो जे अ जेसन वेब
सिग्नेचर के अंदर में आ जाती है जब हम
इंक्रिप्ट कर देते हैं तो जेसन वेब
इंक्रिप्शन के अंदर में उसको हम डिनोट
करते हैं उसको हम बोलते हैं फिलहाल के लिए
हम दोनों टर्म्स को भी समझेंगे अलग-अलग से
तब आपको और भी ज्यादा क्लियर हो जाएगा अब
देखो जेडब्ल्यू t तीन पार्ट में डिवाइड
होता है जेडब्ल्यू t जो होता है आपका जेसन
वेब टोकन थ्री पार्ट्स उसके होते हैं अब
तीनों पार्ट को थोड़ा हम समझ लेते हैं
पहला पार्ट होता है हेडर दूसरा होता है
पेलोड तीसरा होता है सिग्नेचर ये तीन
पार्ट्स होते हैं ठीक है बहुत इजी है कोई
ज्यादा इसमें टफ नहीं चीज टफ चीज नहीं है
अब मैं इसको नेक्स्ट स्लाइड पे आपको करता
हूं तो आपको समझ में आएगा ये एक जेसन वेब
टोकन का एग्जांपल है जो आप यहां पे देख
रहे हैं ये एक टोकन है ठीक है अब इसको ना
मैं ऐसे यहां पे भी दिखा देता हूं पोर्ट
फिगर पे यहां पे एक टोकन यहां पे हमारे
पास है तो ये टोकन है जेसन वेब टोकन
जेडब्ल्यूडी अब आप सोचते हैं ना आप पूछते
हैं ना कि भैया कोई कोई एपीआई सीक्रेट की
मिल गई है किसी तरह का कोई की मिल गया है
किसी तरह का कोई टोकन मिल गया है तो उसका
हम क्या यूज करेंगे किस तरह से इस्तेमाल
करेंगे तो अगर कहीं आपको जेडब्ल्यू कहीं
आपको जेसन वेब टोकन मिल जाते हैं तो उसके
अंदर की इंफॉर्मेशन किस तरीके से वो साइंड
है क्या उसके साइनिंग प्रोसेस में किसी
तरह का मैल अ किसी तरह का कुछ ऐसा मैल
प्रैक्टिस है या कुछ इस तरीके की चीज है
जो कंप्रोमाइज हो जा रही है सही से वोह
बेसिकली
कॉन्फिडो वेरीफाई सही से नहीं हो पा रही
है अलग-अलग चीजों को देखने के बाद हम
डिसाइड करेंगे कि एगजैक्टली हम इस टोकन के
साथ क्या कर सकते हैं एंड इस टोकन को हम
रिपोर्ट करेंगे तो किस तरह की
सीवियरिंग यह आप लाइव जो टारगेट्स है उसके
लिए भी सेम अप्रोच आपको यूज करना है कुछ
नहीं करना है मैं आपको तरीका बताता हूं बस
उसको ध्यान से देखते जाइए बहुत आसान हो
जाएगा जिस जैसे ही जेडब्ल्यू टकंस आपको
मिलेंगे ऑटोमेटिक आपको जो है एसटीटीपी
हिस्ट्री में वो पॉपलेट हो जाएगा एंड आपको
समझ में आ जाएगा अरे यहां तो जेडब्ल्यू है
तो सारी चीजें हम देखेंगे फिलहाल के लिए
ये एक एग्जांपल है जेडब्ल्यूडी टोकन का
थ्री पार्ट्स होते हैं एक हेडर होता है एक
पेलोड होता है और एक सिग्नेचर होता है जो
पहला पार्ट होता है ये वाला पार्ट आप देख
रहे होंगे दिस इज पार्ट दिस पार्ट इज नोन
एज हेडर पार्ट हेडर पार्ट इस जेड डी टोकन
का ही मेटा डाटा कंडक्ट करता है कंटेन
करता है और कुछ नहीं होता है इसमें सो
दूसरा जो पार्ट है वो होता है हमारा पेलोड
जो कि आप यहां से यहां तक का देख सकते हैं
यह आपका पेलोड पार्ट होता है पेलोड पार्ट
में एक्चुअल जो क्लेम्म इंफॉर्मेशन बोलते
हैं यहां पे डाटा बोल रहे हैं यहां पे वो
क्लेम्म है इसको बोला जाता है
क्लेम्म की बात करते हैं तो हम उसको
क्लेम्म उसको कुछ और बोलेंगे इंफॉर्मेशन
जो है
पेलोड पार्ट हो जाता है और तीसरा जो पार्ट
होता है वो आपका हो जाता है सिग्नेचर
पार्ट जहां पे एक्चुअली जो है वो बेसिकली
इनकोडेड या इंक्रिप्टेड फॉर्म में अवेलेबल
होता है अलग-अलग तरह की इंक्रिप्शन
एल्गोरिदम जो है वहां पे यूज हो रही होती
है चाहे वो एसएचएल हो या कोई सा भी हो रहा
हो बट इंक्रिप्शन एल्गोरिदम वहां पे यूज
हो रही होती है वो सिमेट्री हो या सिमेटिक
हो डजन मैटर ठीक है चलिए तो ये तो
जेडब्ल्यू का फॉर्मेट हो गया अब आपको क्या
पता है अभी तक फिलहाल के लिए कि
जेडब्ल्यूडी होते क्या है जसन वेब टोकन एक
सेल्फ कंटेंट में थर्ड है सिक्योर
ट्रांसमिट करने के लिए इंफॉर्मेशन को
जिसको हम
क्लेम्म दो
डिवाइसेसपोर्ट
होता है स्टार्टिंग वाला जो एक डॉट के
पहले जो जितनी भी इंफॉर्मेशन है वो आपका
हेडर होता है उस डॉट के बाद से लेके दूसरे
डॉट तक जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन होती है जो येलो
कलर में आपको दिख रही है वो पेलोड होता है
और लास्ट डॉट जो होती है उसके बाद की
जितनी इंफॉर्मेशन है वो सब सिग्नेचर होते
हैं ठीक है तो ये आपको अब बिल्कुल क्लियर
हो गया होगा अब इसको थोड़ा सा समझते हैं
एंड देन हम इसके अप्रोच पे आते हैं कि किस
तरीके से हमें इसको अप्रोच करना होता है
बेसिकली ठीक है चलिए अब यहां पे नीचे नीचे
की तरफ आते हैं एंड यहां पे फिर से सेम
चीज है यहां पे कि आर स्टैंडर्डाइज
फॉर्मेट फॉर सेंडिंग क्रिप्टोग्राफिकली
साइंड जेसन डेटा बिटवीन सिस्टम जेसन डाटा
को भेजने के लिए जो कि क्रिप्टोग्राफिकली
साइंड होते हैं ताकि उनकी इंटीग्रिटी को
मेंटेन किया जा सकता है कॉन्फिडेंशियल्टी
को उस डटा के मेंटेन किया जा सके दे कैन
थियोरेटिकली कंटेन एनी काइंड ऑफ डाटा किसी
भी तरह का कोई डाटा जेसन फॉर्मेट में किसी
भी तरह का कोई डटा हो सकता है बट आर मोस्ट
कॉमनली यूज्ड टू सेंड इंफॉर्मेशन जिसको कि
हम
क्लेम्म हैंडलिंग और एक्सेस कंट्रोल
मैकेनिज्म तो तीन तरह के जनरली जो है डाटा
उसमें ट्रेवल कर रहे होते हैं यूजर के
रिगार्डिंग ऑथेंटिकेशन से रिलेटेड हो सेशन
हैंडलिंग से हो एक्सेस कंट्रोल मैकेनिज्म
अब ये तीनों ही बहुत सीवियर थिंग्स हैं जब
बात करते हैं हम किसी तरह की एक्सेस का
किसी तरह का कॉम्प्रोमाइज का तो वहां पे
यहां पे जो हमारा जेडब्ल्यू t है वो हो
जाता है पॉपुलर बट इसमें अभी और भी चीजें
हैं जो आपको समझनी है उसको हम देखते हैं
अब यहां पे
देखिए जेडब्ल्यूडी के तीन पार्ट यहां सेम
चीज है जो हमने अभी डिस्कस की है अब इसको
देखते हैं द हेडर एंड पलट पार्ट ऑफ जेडटी
आर जस्ट बेस 64 यूआरएल इनकोडेड जेसन
ऑब्जेक्ट्स जो हेडर और पेलोड होते हैं वो
बेस 64 यरल इनकोडेड जेसन ऑब्जेक्ट्स होते
हैं बस सिंपल अब द हेडर कंटेंस मेटा डाटा
अबाउट द टोकन इट सेल्फ हेडर में क्या होता
है उस टोकन का ही एक मेटा डाटा होता है जो
कि स्टोर्ड होता है वाइल द पेलोड कंटेंस द
एक्चुअल
क्लेम्म कंटेन करता है जैसे यह जो है आपका
यह वाला यह पेलोड है तो इसमें यूजर के
क्लेम यानी यूजर के इंफॉर्मेशन स्टोर्ड
होते हैं अब देखिए क्या होता
है फॉर एग्जांपल यू कैन डिकोड द पेलोड
फ्रॉम एव टोकन टू रिवील द फॉलोइंग
क्लेम्म रिवील कर सकते हैं ऊपर के पेलोड
को डिकोड करके यानी कि ये जो पॉइंट है
यहां से यहां तक का यह पेलोड पॉइंट है
इसको डिकोड आप कर सकते हैं एंड आपको यह
इंफॉर्मेशन मिलेगी कि इस पोथ स्विगर
एग्जाम एक्सपायरी आपका दिया हुआ है यहां
पे नेम सब रोल ईमेल आईएटी यहां पे सब कुछ
दिया हुआ है ठीक है तो ये डिटेल्स यहां पे
कुछ उसमें से निकल के आ रही है अब इस
डिटेल में आप देखेंगे तो एक ईमेल करके
डिटेल है एक यू कैन से हियर नेम आ रहा है
आपका ठीक है तो अलग-अलग डिटेल्स यहां पे आ
रहे हैं तो अब जो है यहां पे इन डिटेल्स
को डिकोड करने के लिए वैसे आप लेटेस्ट अगर
बब सूट का कोई वर्जन यूज कर रहे हैं तो
वहां पे जब आप जेडब्ल्यू t टोकन आपको कहीं
पे मिलता है तो जैसे ही आप पेलोड पार्ट को
सेलेक्ट करते हैं ना कुछ इस तरीके से
ऑटोमेटिक ये डिकोड हो जाता है राइट साइड
के एक इंस्पेक्टर में लेकिन जब पुराना
हमारा अगर कोई बब सूट का वर्जन है तो वहां
पे आप डिकोडर का यूज कर सकते हैं डिकोड
करने के लिए या तो सिंपली जो है आप एक
वेबसाइट है हमारा jwt.io ठीक है jwt.io इस
वेबसाइट का यूज कर सकते हैं jwt.io ठीक है
दिस इज अ गुड वेबसाइट यहां पे मैं यहां पे
देख सकता हूं व्हाट इज दिस
अगेन
जेडटीटी मैं एक बार इसको सर्च कर लेता हूं
बिल्कुल आईओ ओके दिस वाज आ jwt.io तो इस
पे आ जाइएगा एंड यहां पे आके आप जो है
जैसे यहां पे इनकोडेड टोकन है तो इसको मैं
रिमूव कर देता हूं मैं सेम जो है ना यहां
पे सेम इनकोडेड टोकन पूरा का पूरा यहां से
कॉपी मार दूंगा मैंने यहां पे कॉपी मारा
पेस्ट मारा तो यह डिकोड होके यहां पे आ
जाएगा कि आप देख सकते हैं के आईडी यहां पे
दी गई है एलजी यहां पे यूज हो रहा है जो
कि एल्गोरिदम जिसको आप बोल रहे हैं यहां
पे rs256 यूज हो रहा है उसके बाद ये ये
देखिए पेलो डाटा जो यहां पे एगजैक्टली
डिकोड होके आया हुआ है पेलो डटा जो सेम
डाटा है जो वहां पे बब्स वेब सिक्योरिटी प
आपको जो डेटा यहां पे मिल रही है सेम डाटा
यहां पे डिकोड होके आई है एक्सपायर नेम सब
ल ईमेल आईटी ये सारी डाटा आपको यहां पे
निकल के आ चुकी है ठीक है तो यहां पे
डिटेल ये पलट का डाटा है नीचे आप आएंगे
यहां पे तो यहां पे आप देखेंगे आरएस ए एसए
ए 2 256 जो इंक्रिप्शन है यहां पे एंड
यहां पे आ रहा है कि आप यहां पे पब्लिक की
दीजिए प्राइवेट की दीजिए अब इसलिए ऐसा आ
रहा है क्योंकि जो आर एस ए एस एए 256 यहां
पे आपको जो इंक्रिप्शन दिख रही है rs256
दिस इंक्रिप्शन इज इज सिमेट्री इंक्रिप्शन
सिमेट्री है जहां पे वेरिफिकेशन के लिए
पब्लिक की होती है और इंक्रिप्शन करने के
लिए प्राइवेट की का यूज किया जाता है तो
यहां पे आपसे मांगा जा रहा है कि वो
पब्लिक की और प्राइवेट की दीजिए देन आप इस
पर्टिकुलर
इस पर्टिकुलर की जेडब्ल्यूडी टोकेंस को
साइन कर सकते हैं एंड सिग्नेचर सिग्नेचर
जो है ना साइन करके आप इसको वेरीफाई कर
सकते हैं यानी कि कहने का मतलब यह हुआ कि
अगर किसी तरह से यह पब्लिक या प्राइवेट की
अगर लीक मिल जाती है किसी जेसन वेब टोकन
के तो इट मींस कि हम किसी भी तरह का कोई
छेड़छाड़ कर सकते हैं इन पर्टिकुलर पेलोड
के अंदर में यानी कि इस पेलोड में यूजर की
ईमेल आईडी डाली है कार्लोस कालोस मया नेट
अगर हम यहां पे इस पर्टिकुलर यहां जो
हमारे पास ईमेल है मैं इसको कॉपी करता हूं
एंड लेट्स सपोज मैंने यहां पे ईमेल डाला
और इसको अगर हमने यहां पे चेंज टू इस
तरीके से कुछ कर दिया
अटैकर @ gmail.com कुछ ये ईमेल आईडी हमने
चेंज कर दिया तो चेंज कर देंगे और अगर
यहां पे प्रॉपर प्रॉपर अगर सिक्योरिटी लगी
है प्रॉपर तरीके से हैंडल हो रहा है यह
टोकन तो यहां पे हम बिना पब्लिक की
प्राइवेट की के इसको साइन नहीं कर पाते
हैं लेकिन अगर वही कुछ मिस कॉन्फिन है
किसी तरह का सिग्नेचर मिस कॉन्फिन साइनिंग
में मिस मिस कॉन्फिन किसी तरह के कोई
एल्गोरिदम का मिस कॉन्फिन है वहां पे
डेवलपर ने की है तो वहां पे हमारी जो है
ना वहां पे हमारी एजिस्ट हैंस आती है एंड
वहां पे हम जो है बिना इसके भी इस
पर्टिकुलर डेटा को साइन या फिर यूं कहें
कि हम इसमें चेंजेज ला सकते हैं वो चेंजेज
जो है रिफ्लेक्ट कर जाएगी एंड जैसे ही हम
चेंजेज कर देंगे जैसे ही अगर ये ईमेल आईडी
चेंज हो जाती है @ gmail.com को तो हम
अकाउंट कॉम्प्रोमाइज भी कर सकते हैं
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन भी कर सकते हैं वी
कैन डू व्हाट एवर अ वी हैव टू डू ऑन
पर्टिकुलर चेंजिंग द ईमेल आईडी जो भी ईमेल
आईडी चेंज अगर हम कर देते हैं तो इस तरीके
से अकाउंट टेकओवर जो है वो भी होती है
एग्जीक्यूट होती है जब आप जेडब्ल्यूडी
टोकन जसन वेब टोकेंस को बेसिकली अगर एक एक
मिस कन्फर जेसन वेब टोकन को आपको मिल जाती
है एंड उसके बाद आप उसको जो है एक्सप्लोइट
कर देते हैं तो यहां पे फिलहाल के लिए यह
तो आपको जे डब्ल्यूटीए बारे में समझ में आ
गया जिसमें कि हेडर एंड पलट के बारे में
समझ में आ गया ठीक है भैया कि ये ये ऊपर
वाला हेडर पार्ट हो गया जो कि उसी का मेटा
डाटा कंडक्ट करता है जो आपके टोकन है
उसमें कुछ खास नहीं है यहां पे एंड ये रहा
हमारा पलट जो हमारे बहुत ज्यादा काम का है
एंड उसके बाद जो हमारा इन दोनों के बीच
में आ जाती है सिग्नेचर ठीक है अब आ जा
हैं सिग्नेचर सिग्नेचर क्या होता है वो
देखिए द सर्वर दैट इश्यूज द टोकन जो सर्वर
टोकन इशू करता है जेडब्ल्यूडी टिपिकली
जनरेट द सिग्नेचर बाय हैचिंग द हेडर एंड
पेलोड सिग्नेचर जो जनरेट होता है ना वो
हेडर एंड पेलोड को ही हैश करके जनरेट किया
जाता है लेकिन कई केसेस में जो रिजल्टिंग
हैश होता है उसको भी इंक्रिप्ट कर दिया
जाता है दैट आल्सो गेट एनक्रिप्टेड एक तो
हैश किया हेडर का एंड पेलोड का तीन पार्ट
में है भैया हेडर पेलोड और सिग्नेचर तो
हेडर एंड पेलोड को जो हैश कर दिया वही
हमारा क्या हो जाता है वो सिग्नेचर जनरेट
करने के लिए यूज़ में लिया जाता है एंड सम
टाइम्स दे आल्सो एंक्रिप्ट द रिजल्टिंग
हैश रिजल्टिंग हैश को भी इंक्रिप्ट कर
दिया जाता है इदर वे दिस प्रोसेस इवॉल्व अ
सीक्रेट साइनिंग की एक सीक्रेट साइनिंग की
हो जा एक होती है वहां पे दिस मैकेनिज्म
प्रोवाइड्स अ वे फॉर सर्वर टू वेरीफाई दैट
नन ऑफ द डेटा ऑफ द टोकन हैज बीन टेंपर्ड
विथ कोई भी डेटा टेंपर्ड नहीं हुई यह
वेरीफाई करने के लिए य सीक्रेट साइनिंग की
बहुत जरूरी है तो सीक्रेट साइनिंग की इज द
की फॉर दिस काइंड ऑफ अटैक्स यह सीक्रेट
साइनिंग की एक की है दूसरा कि किसी तरह का
कोई मिस कन्फेशन है वह भी जो है व भी इशू
करता है यहां पे वो भी दिक्कत करेगी फिर
हमारे इस इस पर्टिकुलर अटैक में ठीक है अब
देखिए
द दिस मैकेनिज्म प्रोवाइड्स अ वे फॉर
सर्वर टू वेरीफाई दैट नन ऑफ द डाटा विद इन
द टोकन हैज बीन टेंपर्ड विथ सिंस इट वाज
इश्यूड एज द सिग्नेचर इज डायरेक्टली डराइड
फ्रॉम द रेस्ट ऑफ द टोकन क्योंकि बाकी
टोकन से ही सिग्नेचर डिराइवर हो रहा है
कहां से हो रहा है हमारे हेडर एंड पेलोड
से चेंजिंग अ सिंगल बाइट ऑफ द हेडर और
पेलोड रिजल्ट्स इन अ मिसमैच सिग्नेचर अगर
आपने पेलोड में अब यहां पे सिक्योरिटी
वाली बात क्या आ जाती है कि अगर आपने
पेलोड में किसी तरह का कोई चेंज किया जैसे
कि मैंने यहां पे ईमेल आईडी में ये चेंज
कर दिया था अब जैसे ही मैंने ये चेंज किया
यहां पे सिग्नेचर मिसमैच करेगा सिग्नेचर
चेंज हो जाएगी पूरी तरीके से क्योंकि उसी
हेडर एंड उसी पलट से ये सिग्नेचर डिराइवर
की गई है और जैसे ही सिग्नेचर चेंज होगी
तो सर्वर बोलेगा भैया यह तो गलत सिग्नेचर
आपने डाला है यह तो गलत सिग्नेचर से साइन
किया है साइनिंग की सही नहीं है तो हम
आपका ये मॉडिफिकेशन जो आपने किया है ईमेल
चेंज किया है उसको हम अप्रूव नहीं करते
हैं दिस इज द सिक्योरिटी पार्ट बट विदाउट
नोइंग द सर्वर सीक्रेट साइनिंग की इट शुड
नॉट बी पॉसिबल टू जनरेट द करेक्ट सिग्नेचर
फॉर अ गिवन हेडर और पेलोड तो बिना मतलब
सीक्रेट साइनिंग की के आप करेक्ट सिग्नेचर
नहीं जनरेट कर सकते हैं तो यह तो नॉर्मल
सा सिनेरियो हो गया लेकिन अब अटैकर मोड
वाला सिनेरियो जो दिमाग में हमारे चल रहा
है वो क्या हो सकता है कि दो तरीके हैं या
तो आप इस पर्टिकुलर सीक्रेट शाइनिंग की को
ये सीक्रेट साइनिंग की को कंप्रोमाइज ही
कर ले कहीं से आपको ये सीक्रेट साइनिंग की
मिल जाता है लेट्स सपोज अगर सिमेट्री के
केस में है तो एक सीक्रेट की आपको मिल
जाती है असमेट है तो पब्लिक और प्राइवेट
दोनों मिल जाती है ठीक है एक तरीका तो ये
हो गया दूसरा या तो आप इस सीक्रेट साइनिंग
की को ब्रूट फोर्स कर पाए किसी भी तरीके
से जो कि हालांकि इजी नहीं होगा लेकिन
स्टिल अगर कर पाए तो फिर उस केस में आपकी
बात बन जाती है तीसरा यहां पे क्या होगा
कि अगर इस पर्टिकुलर सीक्रेट साइनिंग की
के रिजल्ट जो ये सिग्नेचर वेरीफाई करने का
तरीका है उस तरीके में किसी तरह का
मिसकंफीग्रेशन है हमारे डेवलपर भाई साहब
के तरफ से कुछ कर दिया गलती से कुछ मिस
कंफीग्रेशन हो गई है तो उसको हमने पकड़
लिया तो वहां से फिर हमें जो है वो
पर्टिकुलर हम चेंजेज कर सकते हैं यानी कि
हम अब इसमें ये हो सकता है कि यह जो
सीक्रेट साइन की है जो सिग्नेचर है या तो
यह सिग्नेचर वेरीफाई ही नहीं हो रही है
सही से सर्वर साइड से तो वहां पे हम
कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर सकते हैं जडब्ल्यू टोकन
और जो चेंजेज चाहे कर सकते हैं और यूजर
अकाउंट कंप्रोमाइज कर सकते हैं एस्केलेट
कर सकते हैं अपने प्रिविलेज कोकलेट कर
सकते हैं या तो सिग्नेचर की हमने हटा दिया
तब भी सर्वर उसको एक्सेप्ट कर रहा है उस
केस में भी कर सकते देयर आर मल्टीपल
सिनेरियो दैट वी कैन लुक फॉर कि हम
क्या-क्या चीजें कर सकते हैं तो बेसिकली
आज जो हम अभी क्लास जो कर रहे हैं इसमें
हम एक पर्टिकुलर टोकन के ऊपर फोकस कर रहे
हैं जैसे कि बाकी टोकन होते हैं और उसको
एक्सप्लोइट करने का जो तरीका होता है
जिससे कि आप उस पर्टिकुलर वलने एबिलिटी को
एक्सप्लोइट करके एंड देन आप उसको रिपोर्ट
कर सकते हैं एक अच्छा रिपोर्ट बना के देन
हम उस पे फोकस कर रहे हैं तो चलिए अब यहां
पे जेडब्ल्यू t जेडब्ल्यूएस और जेडब्ल्यू
ई में थोड़ा सा डिफरेंस समझ लेते हैं अब
देखो जेडब्ल्यू टी जो होता है उसी को दो
पार्ट में एक्सटेंड किया जाता है जेडब्लूए
जेसन वेब सिग्नेचर जेडब्ल्यू जेसन वेब
इंक्रिप्शन हालांकि है यह जेडब्ल्यू का ही
एक्सटेंशन पार्ट देखिए जेडटी स्पेसिफिकेशन
इज एक्चुअली वेरी लिमिटेड ठीक है इट ओनली
डिफाइंस अ फॉर्मेट फॉर रिप्रेजेंटिंग
इंफॉर्मेशन जिसको हम क्लेमसेंटर
इसको यूज़ सिर्फ एक फॉर्मेट के लिए किया
जा सकता है एक फॉर्मेट के लिए दिखाने के
लिए कि भैया जसन ऑब्जेक्ट्स को जो है इस
फॉर्मेट में हम ट्रांसफर कर रहे हैं जिसको
हम लेम्स बोलते हैं दैट कैन बी ट्रांसफर्ड
ठीक है इन प्रैक्टिस इन एक्चुअल प्रैक्टिस
में क्या हो जाता है जेडब्ल्यू टी आर नॉट
रियली यूज्ड एज अ स्टैंड अलोन एंटिटी
जेडटी स्पेक इज एक्सटेंडेड बाय बोथ जेसन
वेब सिगनेचर्स एंड जेसन वेब इंक्रिप्शन
स्पेसिफिकेशन व्हिच कैन डिफाइन कंक्रीट
वेज ऑफ एक्चुअली इंप्लीमेंटिंग जीडब्ल्यू
अब देखिए क्या होता है
जेडब्ल्यू या तो जेडब्ल्यूएस होता है या
जेडब्ल्यू टोकन होता है व्हेन पीपल यूज द
टर्म जेडब्ल्यू t दे ऑलमोस्ट ऑलवेज मींस
जेडब्ल्यूएस टोकन हमेशा वो जेडब्ल्यूएस
इसका मतलब जेसन वेब सिग्नेचर इसका मतलब हम
मानते हैं जेडब्लूज आर वेरी सिमिलर
एक्सेप्ट द द एक्चुअल कंटेंस ऑफ द टोकन
एंड इनक्रिप्टेड रदर देन जस्ट इनकोडेड
मतलब कि हमारा जो
जेडब्लूकैड ब्लूटी हमारा टोकन हो गया यह
टोकन क्या जेडब्ल्यू होता है जेसन वेब
टोकन ठीक है तो जनरली क्या होता है कि
इसको दो फॉर्मेट में वो हम देखते हैं
जेडब्ल्यूएस जेसन वेब सिग्नेचर और एक होता
है जेडब्ल्यू जेसन वेब इंक्रिप्शन अब
इसमें जेडब्ल्यूएस में क्या हो जाता है ना
जेडब्ल्यूएस ये एक तरह का इनकोडेड जो
फॉर्म होता है आपका टोकन का वो आपका
जेडब्ल्यूएस में कंसीडर कर लेते हैं हम
एंड यहीं पे अगर हम इंक्रिप्टेड
इसमें प्लस इंक्रिप्टेड फॉर्म में अगर हम
लेकर आ जाते हैं तो यह जेडब्ल्यू से जेसन
वेब इंक्रिप्शन में जो है ये हमारा कंसीडर
होने लगता है तो यहां पे फिर आप जब
इंक्रिप्टेड होगी तो यहां पे दो तरह की
होती है अ मेट्रिक य हो सकती है या तो
यहां
पे सिमेट्री यहां पे दोनों में से कोई सा
भी जो है वो हो सकती है ये स्पेलिंग देख
लीजिएगा जो भी है और सिमेट्री या
अम सिमेट्री या फिर आपका ये हो जाता है
ठीक है अब यहां पे ये लाइट इतनी कम कैसे
होगी ओके ओके ये सि इसके लिए ठीक है तो ये
आपका जेडब्लूए और जेडब्ल्यू पार्ट जो होता
है इसका एक्सटेंशन पार्ट ये होता है तो
अगर कोई आपसे पूछता है टेक्निकल अगर ऐसा
है तो आप जेसन वेब सिग्नेचर ही बोलेंगे
अगर वो नॉन इनक्रिप्टेड है तो सिर्फ
इनकोडेड है अगर एक इनकोडेड एंड
इंक्रिप्टेड दोनों ही हमारा टोकन है तो वो
जेडब्ल्यू कैटेगरी में आप इसको डाल सकते
हैं इसके रिगार्डिंग आप आरएफसी भी पढ़
सकते हैं बहुत डिटेल में है तो आपको और भी
ज्यादा इसकी इंफॉर्मेशन मिल सकती है अगर
आप जाना चाहते हैं अदर वाइज कोई बात नहीं
ठीक है
चलिए अब यहां पे समझते हैं कि ये
जेडब्ल्यू अटैक्स एगजैक्टली क्या होता है
जेडब्ल्यू अटैक्स इवॉल्व अ यूजर सेंड
मॉडिफाइड जेडब्ल्यू टू द सर्वर मॉडिफाइड
जो जेडब्ल्यू होते हैं सर्वर तक भेजने के
लिए वो हमारा जेडब्ल्यू अटैक होता है आप
मुझे पहले यह बताइए यहां तक आप सबको जे
डब्ल्यूटीए यहां तक यह बता दीजिए मुझे
जल्दी से क्लियर कर दीजिए
फटाफट जल्दी से क्लिक क्लिक
क् यहां तक अभी तक क्लियर है सबका सर हम
आगे बढ़ते हैं राइट एवरीथिंग इ क्लियर
राइट आपको ये कॉम्लेक्स लगा अभी तक ऐसा
लगा कि यह बहुत
कॉम्प्लेक्टेड टीचिंग स्किल्स अमेजिंग
थैंक यू बैटमैन थैंक यू आई एम फैन आई एम
ऑलरेडी अ फैन ऑफ बैटमैन सो बैटमैन बैटमैन
भी हमारे वीडियो को देख रहे अच्छी बात है
गुड स्पाइडरमैन और बाकी जो मैन है वो भी आ
जाना अभी तक इजी है इजी है ना हां अभी तक
इजी इसलिए है क्योंकि मैंने आपको इजी बना
के दिया है ये इजी नहीं है लिटरली मैं बता
रहा हूं आप जेडब्ल्यू के बारे में बहुत
सारे हंटर्स जो होते हैं जो बिगिनर्स होते
हैं उस उनका दिमाग काम करना बंद कर देता
है वो समझते हैं अरे क्या हो क्या रहा है
ये है क्या ये ये सारी चीजें तो इजी बनाया
गया है इसको ठीक है अब
देखिए जेडब्ल्यू अटैक्स इवॉल्व अ यूजर
सेंडिंग मॉडिफाइड जेडब्ल्यू टू द सर्वर
मॉडिफाइड पेलोड के अंदर मॉडिफिकेशन करते
हैं और कोई मॉडिफिकेशन होती नहीं है पेलोड
के अंदर में क्योंकि उसी के अंदर डाटा
होता है जो हमें चाहिए भाई टू अचीव अ
मलेशियन गोल वही ईमेल आईडी चेंज कर दिया
मालीशियस समझ गए हैकर का ईमेल डाल दिया
टिपिकली दिस गोल इज टू बायपास ऑथेंटिकेशन
एंड एक्सेस कंट्रोल्स बाय इंपर्सनेटिंग
अनदर यूजर हु हैज ऑलरेडी बीन ऑथेंटिकेटेड
अब यार कोई ऐसा है यूजर जो ऑलरेडी पहले से
उस सिस्टम में है उस एप्लीकेशन पे है
लॉगिन है उसका अब उसका ईमेल आईडी डाल दिया
और पता चले कि हम उसके अकाउंट में लॉग इन
हो गए हैं हमारा यह जेडब्ल्यूडी टोकन से
तो फिर यह तो बहुत बड़ी एक हाई सीवियरिंग
की वलने बिलिटी कंसीडर की जाएगी क्योंकि
आप वहां पे ऑथेंटिक केशन बायपास कर रहे
हैं एक तरह से तो दिस विल बी कंसीडर्ड एज
p1 प2 डिपेंडिंग ऑन व्हाट टाइप ऑफ यूजर यू
आर एक्सप्लोइटिंग करेंटली राइट अब कोई
टेस्ट यूजर होगा तो उसका तो कोई मतलब ही
नहीं बनता है लेकिन अगर कोई प्रोडक्शन कोई
ऐसा यूजर होगा जो एगजैक्टली जो है काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट है उस ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के लिए एंड
वो लेवल ऑफ जो लेवल प्रिविलेज मिल रही है
वो इंपॉर्टेंट प्रिविलेज है तो फिर तो
बहुत हाई सवेरिन हो जाएगी अब देखिए यहां
पे द इंपैक्ट ऑफ जेडब्ल्यू अटैक्स इज
यूजुअली सीवियर सीवियर ही होता है इफ एन
अटैकर इज एबल टू क्रिएट देर ओन वैलिड
टोकेंस खुद का वैलिड टोकन अगर बना लिया
अटैकर ने विथ आर्बिट्री वैल्यूज दे मे बी
एबल टू एस्केलेट देयर ओन प्रिविलेज और
इंपर्सनेट अदर यूजर टेकिंग फुल कंट्रोल ऑफ
देर अकाउंट यानी कि प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
भी हो सकती है ऑथेंटिकेशन बायपास भी हो
सकता है कुछ भी हो सकता है डिपेंड करता है
अब देखिए यहां पे हाउ डू लेबिलिटी टूू
जेडब्ल्यू अटैक्स राइज ये कैसे मतलब राइज
कैसे कर रहे हैं जेडब्ल्यू इज टिपिकली
अराइज ड्यू टू फ्लड जेडब्ल्यू हैंडलिंग
विद द एप्लीकेशन इट सेल्फ फ्लड हैंडलिंग
की वजह से होता है द वेरियस स्पेसिफिकेशन
रिलेटेड टू जेडब्लूज आर रिलेटिवली
फ्लेक्सिबल बाय डिजाइन अलांग वेबसाइट
डेवलपर्स टू रिसाइट मेनी इंप्लीमेंटेशंस
डिटेल्स फॉर देम सेल्व ठीक है ना अब इसमें
क्या हो जाता है कि जो डेवलपर होते हैं
बेचारे उनके साइड से प्रॉब्लम हो जाती है
थोड़ी सी क्या होती है दज इंप्लीमेंटेशन
फ्लज यूजुअली मीन दैट द सिग्नेचर ऑफ़ द
जेडब्ल्यू इज नॉट वेरीफाइड प्रॉपर्ली
सिग्नेचर को प्रॉपर्ली वेरीफाई नहीं किया
गया है दिस इनेबल्स एन अटैकर टू टेंपर विद
द वैल्यूज पास्ड टू द एप्लीकेशन वाय
टोकेंस पेलोड पेलोड से इवन इफ द सिग्नेचर
इ रोबट वेरीफाइड वेदर इट कैन ट्रूली बी
ट्रस्टेड रिलाइज हैवली ऑन द सर्वर सीक्रेट
की रिमेनिंग अ सीक्रेट अब सीक्रेट की ही
कंप्रोमाइज हो जाए भाई सर्वर की मान लो तो
फिर क्या होगा अब मान लो कि आप एक ऐसे
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अंदर हो के ऊपर टेस्ट कर
रहे हो उसकी पर्टिकुलर एप्लीकेशन को टेस्ट
कर रहे हो उस ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अंदर में आप
घुसे हो और वहां से आप स्निफ कर ले रहे हो
सीक्रेट की को आपके पास सीक्रेट की आ गई
है वो एक सिमिट्रिक की इंक्रिप्शन यूज हो
रहा है वहां पे तो सीक्रेट की तो आपने
निकाल लिया भाई अब सीक्रेट की जब आपने
निकाल लिया तो आप किसी भी तरह का
मॉडिफिकेशन जेडब्ल्यू टोकन में करके और उस
सीक्रेट की से उसको साइन कर सकते हो
सिग्नेचर साइन कर दीजिएगा एंड
दैट्ची की भी जनरेट कर सकते हैं जो कि
साइन करने के लिए आप बेसिकली यूज़ में ले
सकते हैं इफ दिस की इज लीक्ड ऑन सम वे और
कैन बी गेस्ड और ब्रूट फोर्स जैसा कि
मैंने बोला एन अटैकर कैन जनरेट अ वैलिड
सिग्नेचर फ्रॉम एनी आर्बिट्री टोकन
कॉम्प्रोमाइजिंग द एनटायर मैकेनिज्म पूरा
का पूरा मैकेनिज्म ही कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो
जाएगा तो यह बहुत बड़ी बात है अगर हम
देखें तो बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग चीज भी है तो
इसको हम जरूर से जरूर अभी समझेंगे बट इसके
पहले जो है हम यहां पे पहले देखेंगे
एक्सप्लोइटिंग एक्सप्लोइटिंग फ्लड
जेडब्ल्यूडी सिग्नेचर वेरिफिकेशन अब
सिग्नेचर वेरिफिकेशन को एक्सप्लोइट करने
की हम यहां पे तरीके को देखेंगे याद
रखिएगा ये जो तरीका है ये रियल लाइव वेब
एप्लीकेशंस जो भी रियल टारगेट है आप उसपे
भी सेम तरीके से सारी चीजें अप्लाई करेंगे
कुछ अलग नहीं होता है लैब्स इसलिए होते
हैं ताकि हम प्रैक्टिस कर पाएं क्योंकि
हमें वो लेबिलिटी वहां हार्ड कोडेड मिल
जाती है ताकि हम उसको रियल में देख पाएं
कि यहां एगजैक्टली है यह चीज इसको ऐसे
टैकल करेंगे अगर आप लाइव टारगेट पे खोजें
तो उसमें बहुत टाइम लग जा जाता है तो आपको
समझने में दिक्कत होगी वो चीज तो यहां पे
जो चीज हम कर रहे हैं उसको आप लाइव टारगेट
पे अप्लाई कीजिएगा बहुत मजा आएगा आपको
बताऊंगा कैसे खोजा कैसे जाता है मतलब किस
तरीके से आप फाइंड कर सकते हैं कि यहां पे
जेडब्ल्यू यूज हो रहा है टोकन यहां पे जसन
वेब टोकन अवेलेबल है ये भी हम आपको अभी
बताऊंगा थोड़ी देर में ठीक है देखते
जाइए अब देखिए बाय डिजाइन क्या होता है
सर्वर्स डोंट यूजुअली स्टोर एनी
इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट जेडब्ल्यू दैट दे इशू
कोई इंफॉर्मेशन इनके पास जेडब्ल्यू का जो
ये इशू करते हैं होता नहीं है स्टोर करके
नहीं रखते
इंस्टेड ईच टोकन इज एन एंटायस कंटेंट
एंटिटी वो एक सेल्फ कंटेंट एंटिटी है डॉकर
होता है एक सेल्फ कंटेंट एंटिटी उसी तरीके
से यह भी एक सेल्फ कंटेंट एंटिटी है उसके
अंदर सब कुछ आपको मिलेगा दिस आर सेवरल
एडवांटेजेस एडवांटेजेस बहुत है बट आल्सो
इंट्रोड्यूस अ फंडामेंटल प्रॉब्लम द सर्वर
डज नॉट
अलाउ डज नॉट एक्चुअली नो एनीथिंग अबाउट द
ओरिजिनल कंटेंट्स ऑफ़ द टोकन ओरिजिनल
कंटेंट के बारे में सर्वर को बेचारे को
कुछ नहीं पता है हाईली डिपेंड ऑन साइनिंग
सीक्रेट कीज और इवन व्हाट द ओरिजिनल
सिग्नेचर वाज ओरिजिनल सिग्नेचर के बारे
में भी आईडिया नहीं है देयर फॉर इफ द
सर्वर डज नॉट वेरीफाई द सिग्नेचर
प्रॉपर्ली अगर इसीलिए क्योंकि सर्वर को ना
उसके ना तो ओरिजिनल कंटेंट के बारे में
पता है कि उस जेडब्ल्यू के अंदर है क्या
पेलोड और ना तो एग्जैक्ट जो साइनिंग जो की
है सिग्नेचर है उसके बारे में ओरिजिनल
उसको कुछ आईडिया है तो उसको प्रॉपर्ली
वेरीफाई करनी होती है जो मैकेनिज्म है
उसके थ्रू जो सिग्नेचर वेरिफिकेशन का
तरीका है उसके थ्रू उसको वेरीफाई करना
होता है उस वेरिफिकेशन में थोड़ा भी फ्लो
हुआ किसी तरह का कोई मिस कॉन्फिन हुआ वहां
पे हम उसको एक्सप्लोइट कर पाएंगे एंड वहां
पे हम किसी तरह का अकाउंट टेक ओवर कर
पाएंगे प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन कर पाएंगे
व्हाट एवर ठीक है देयर इज
नथिंग
देखो देयर फॉर इफ द सर्वर डज नॉट वेरीफाई
द सिग्नेचर प्रॉपर्ली देयर इज नथिंग टू
स्टॉप एन अटैकर फ्रॉम मेकिंग आर्बिट्री
चेंजेज टू द रेस्ट ऑफ़ द टोकन जाकर अटैकर
को कोई नहीं रोक सकता है यह डिजाइन फ्लॉय
ठीक है डिजाइन फ्लॉक दूर नहीं किया जा
सकता है उसको प्रॉपर एक सिक्योरिटी के तहत
वो किया जा सकता है लेकिन उसको दूर हटाया
नहीं जा सकता क्योंकि उसके डिजाइन में वो
फ्लॉफ एग्जांपल अब देखिए एक जेडब्ल्यू
कंटेनिंग द फॉलोइंग क्लेम है एक जेडब्ल्यू
है जिसमें ये क्लेम्म कार्लोस है इज एडमिन
फॉल्स है मतलब एडमिन नहीं है ये यूजर नेम
कार्लोस इफ द सर्वर आइडेंटिफिकेशन
इट्स वैल्यू माइट इनेबल एन अटैकर टू
इंपर्सनेट अदर लॉग इन यूजेस ठीक है सिर्फ
और सिर्फ यूजर नेम पे अगर कर रहा है तो
भैया यहां पे कार्लोस के जगह पे कोई और
यूजर नेम आ जाएगा एंड क्या होगा कि उसी ल
उसी यूजर को इंपर्सनेट अटैकर कर पाएगा
सिमिलरली इफ द इज एडमिन वैल्यू यूज टू
एक्सेस कंट्रोल यूज फॉर एक्सेस कंट्रोल
दिस कुड प्रोवाइड अ सिंपल वेक्टर फॉर
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन अगर इज एडमिन से ये
बेसिकली एक्सेस कंट्रोल डिफाइन किया जा
रहा है तो यहां पे जो फॉल्स है इसको कोई
ट्रू कर देगा तो ये उस केस में प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन हो जाएगी कि एक नॉर्मल सा यूजर
जो कार्लोस एक नॉर्मल यूजर था वो एक एडमिन
यूजर बन चुका है या कोई भी दूसरा अटैक
अटैकर वाला यूजर हो कोई सा भी हो वो बन
जाएगा तो इस तरीके की चीजें यहां पे की
जाती है अब यहां पे क्या हो जाता है सबसे
पहला जो हमारा डिजाइन फ्लब पहला जो हमारा
मिस कन्फेशन आता है वह आता है एक्सेप्टिंग
आर्बिट्री सिग्नेचर आर्बिट्री सिग्नेचर को
एक्सेप्ट करना ठीक है चलिए अब देखते हैं
जेडब्ल्यू लाइ
टिपिकली प्रोवाइड वन मेथड फॉर वेरीफाइंग
टोकेंस एंड अनदर जस्ट टू डिकोड देम ठीक है
ना अब यहां पर जो जे डब्ल्यूटीपी होते हैं
वह दो मेथड होते हैं एक मेथड वेरीफाई करने
के लिए यहां पर इंट्रोड्यूस किया जाता है
दूसरा जो है वो उसको डिकोड करने के लिए
इंट्रोड्यूस किया जाता है तो नट जेएस का
नट जेएस लाइब्रेरी का एक लाइब्रेरी जो है
जेसन वेब टोकन नोट जस का ही आता है यहां
पे तो जब आप नट जस के बारे में थोड़ा
पढ़ेंगे तो आपको आईडिया मिले
यहां
पे नो जस का एक लाइब्रेरी यहां पे है जसन
वेब टोकेंस ठीक है यह वाला जेसन वेब टोकस
इसमें दो तरह की मेथड पास की जाती है यहां
पे एक जो मेथड है वो वेरीफाई का होता है
और एक जो मेथड होता है वो डिकोड का मेथड
होता है दोनों पास की जाती है ठीक है सेम
चीज जो यहां पे यहां पे बताया गया है जेसन
वेब टोकन में वेरीफाई और डिकोड दो तरह के
मेथड्स को यहां पे पास किया जाता है अब
यहां पे जब कोई डेवलपर होगा ना तो ये इन
दोनों को यूज करेगा इट मींस कि यहां पे
वेरीफाई भी हो रही है डिकोड भी हो रही है
ठीक है डिकोड भी हो रहा है वेरीफाई भी हो
रहा है बट बाय चांस कभी-कभी अटैकर क्या कर
देता है व्हाट हैपेंस कि ये वेरीफाई तो
छोड़ दो सिर्फ डिकोड वाला मेथड यूज कर
लेता है ओनली डिकोड वाली कंफ्यूजन किसी
तरह का किसी तरह का कुछ मिस कन्फेशन की
वजह से यहां पे डिकोड वाली जो मेथड है
उसको यूज किया जाता है और बाकी जो वेरीफाई
है वो गायब हो गई अब इससे होता क्या है
व्हाट हैपेंस ऑकेजनली डेवलपर्स कंफ्यूज द
टू मेथड्स एंड ओनली पास द इनकमिंग टोकेंस
टू डिकोड दिस इफेक्टिवली मींस दैट द
एप्लीकेशन डज नॉट वेरीफाई द सिग्नेचर एट
ऑल उसको सिग्नेचर से कोई मतलब ही नहीं है
फिर तो अटैकर को अटैकर मतलब अटैकर को
सिग्नेचर जो है वहां पे वो बायपास कर लेगा
सिंपल क्योंकि यहां पे जो है उस टोकन को
फिर उस सिग्नेचर से कोई मतलब नहीं वेरीफाई
नहीं करेगा तो इस तरीके की कुछ मिस
कॉन्फिन होती है तो यहां पे आपका जो है ना
आपकी बत्ती जलनी चाहिए एंड आपको मिल जाता
है एक एक्सप्लोइट
जेडब्ल्यू टोकन जेडब्ल्यू टोकन तो उसको आप
एक्सप्लोइट करके ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं अब
देखिए यहां पे सबसे पहले जेडब्ल्यू तरह के
अटैक को आप जब लाइव कर रहे होते हैं जब
प्रैक्टिकली करेंगे तो आपके पास अ मैं
रिकमेंड करूंगा कि आप लेटेस्ट बॉब सूट को
यूज करें लेटेस्ट बॉब सूट में जो
कम्युनिटी एडिशन है आप उसको यूज कर सकते
हैं या तो अगर आपके पास कोई सा भी बॉब सूट
है लेटेस्ट जो नया बॉब सूट है तो उसको आप
यूज कर सकते हैं इसका रीजन है मैं आपको
बताऊंगा हालांकि हालांकि आप पुराना बब सूट
भी यूज कर सकते हैं नहीं फिर उसमें आपको
डिकोडर का यूज करना पड़ेगा इसमें बाय
डिफॉल्ट जो है लेटस में आपको जेडब्ल्यूडी
का जो है वो मिल जाता है डिकोडर चलिए तो
मैं क्या करता हूं मैं बब सूट का जो
कम्युनिटी एडिशन है उसको यूज करूंगा यहां
पे बब सूट कम्युनिटी एडिशन बिल्कुल फ्री
है काली में भी आपको प्रेजेंट मिलेगा
विंडोज में मिल जाएगा आप इसमें सारा काम
कर सकते हैं जेडब्ल्यू से रिलेटेड किसी
तरह का कोई प्रो आपको फीचर की फिलहाल
इसमें कोई नीड नहीं पड़ने वाली है तो मैं
यहां पे बब सूट का कम्युनिटी एडिशन ओपन
करूंगा सिंपली यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं
व्हाट इज
दिस इंस्टॉल्ड है या इंस्टॉल हो रहा है या
क्या हो रहा है एक बार देख लेते हैं जस्ट
लेट्स सी अपडेटिंग बब सूट ओके अपडेट हो
रही है ठीक है चलिए हो जाने देते हैं इसको
फटाफट दो मिनट का टाइम
लगेगा आई थिंक कम्युनिटी एडिशन के लिए यूज
करने के लिए कोई प्रॉब्लम आपको नहीं होगी
कोई भी सिंपल आप बब सूट का ऑफिशियल पोर्ट
फिगर की वेबसाइट से जाके डाउनलोड कीजिए
एंड इसको यूज कीजिए दैट्ची
एंड हम इसको मैं इसको आपको कॉन्फिन
बताऊंगा किस तरीके से आप जेडब्ल्यू के लिए
इसको
कॉन्फिडे फॉल्ट ठीक
है चलिए सो यर वी आर स्टार्टिंग नाउ द बबस
कमटी कम्युनिटी एडिशन यहां आ चुका है यहां
पर नेक्स्ट प क्लिक करते हैं स्टार्ट कर
देते हैं ल स्टार्ट द बब सट कम्युनिटी
एडिशन इसको जूम कर देता हूं मैक्सिमाइज कर
देता हूं
सॉरी अब जैसे ही आप स्टार्ट करेंगे कुछ इस
तरह का इंटरफेस आपको दिखेगा प्रॉक्सी में
चलेंगे इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ है वेल एंड गुड अब जब
यहां जब आप आएंगे तो जब आप एक्सटेंशन पे
जाएंगे एक्सटेंशन पे तो यहां पे आपको बी
एप स्टोर दिखेगा ब एप स्टोर पे चले जाइएगा
एंड यहां पे आप जेडब्ल्यूडी सर्च करिएगा
जेडब्ल्यू t सर्च करेंगे तो आपको
जेडब्ल्यू t एडिटर नाम का एक प्लगइन दिख
जाएगा आपको इसको इंस्टॉल कर लेना है तो
जेडब्ल्यूडी एडिटर जो है ये बर्ब का
एक्सटेंशन है जोसे कि आप जेडब्ल्यू को
एडिट साइन वेरीफाई इनक्रिप्ट डिक्रिप्ट सब
कर सकते हैं तो यह आप कर लीजिएगा ठीक है
पहला चीज तो यहां पे जैसे ही आप जाएंगे
यहां पे आपको यहां पे इंस्टॉल करने का
ऑप्शन मिलेगा आप इंस्टॉल कर लीजिएगा
पुराना वर्जन होगा बब का तो वहां पे आपको
यह बोलेगा कि न्यू वर्जन चाहिए बब का तो
इसलिए मैंने आपको बोला कि लेटेस्ट वर्जन
आप इसको कम्युनिटी एडिशन भी यूज कर सकते
हैं पुराने वर्जन में ये काम नहीं करता है
ठीक है तो आप इसको इंस्टॉल कर लीजिएगा
पहली बात तो इंस्टॉल जब हो जाए ये चीज
उसके बाद आपको कुछ नहीं करना है उसके बाद
आपको यहां पे डैशबोर्ड पे आ जानी है
टारगेट पे आ जाइए चाहे तो इस तरीके
से अब यहां पे आ चुके हैं टारगेट प यहां
पे है आपका प्रॉक्सी यह रहा तो अब जो है
हम क्या करते हैं मैं यहां पे चलता हूं
यहां पे लैब के ऊपर में एंड हमारा जो पहला
लैब है इसको एक बार ओपन कर लेते हैं वी
विल स्टार्ट द फर्स्ट लैब हियर जब यह लैब
हम ओपन करेंगे गाइस तो यहां पे हमें एक
लैब में क्या मिल रहा है कि दिस लैब यूसेज
अ जेडब्ल्यू बेस्ड मैकेनिज्म फॉर हैंडलिंग
सेशंस ठीक है अच्छी बात है ड्यू टू
इंप्लीमेंटेशन फ्लज द सर्वर डज नॉट
वेरीफाई द सिग्नेचर ऑफ एनी जेडब्ल्यू दैट
इट रिसीव कोई भी सिग्नेचर वेरिफिकेशन भैया
हमारा ये नहीं करता है टू सॉल्व द लैब
मॉडिफाई योर सोशन योर सेशन टोकन टू गेन
एक्सेस टू एडमिन पैनल ट स्ल एडमिन देन
डिलीट द यूजर कार्लोस तो मतलब सॉल्व करने
के लिए क्या करना है आपको अपने सेशन टोकन
को मॉडिफाई करना है बेसिकली यहां पे जो भी
आपका सेशन टोकन आ रहा है टू गेन एक्सेस टू
द एडमिन पैनल ठीक है कुसी तरह का कुछ
मॉडिफिकेशन करेंगे चलिए अच्छी बात है अब
हम इसको यूज़ करके कोशिश करते हैं एक्सेस
लैब करने की कोशिश करते हैं तो एक्सेस द
लैब हम यहां पे क्लिक करते हैं तो यहां पे
लैब जो है हमारा एक्सेस होना स्टार्ट हो
जाएगा ठीक है तो लेट्स एक्सेस द लैब हियर
फर्स्ट हम तो आ चुके हैं हम यहां पे अब
यहां पे माय अकाउंट है ऑप्शन यहां पे आपको
मिल रहा है यहां पे आप विनर पीटर से लॉगइन
कर सकते हैं यहां पे ऑलरेडी दे रखा हुआ है
तो हम क्या कर देते हैं कि विनर पीटर को
लॉगइन के लिए यूज़ कर सकते हैं उसके पहले
हम क्या करेंगे बब स्ट पे चलेंगे यहां पे
एंड यहां पे जब हम बब सूट के ऊपर आएंगे तो
यहां हम जो बब सूट वाली जो प्रॉक्सी है
उसको पहले हम इनेबल कर देंगे ठीक है तो
व्हाट आई एम गोइंग टू डू आई एम गोइंग टू
इनेबल द बब प्रॉक्सी एंड देन हम माय
अकाउंट पे चलते हैं देन वी आर गोइंग टू
माय अकाउंट यहां पे लॉग इन करते
हैं विनर एंड पीटर लॉगइन से एंड यहां पे
हम लॉग इन कर लेते हैं ठीक है हमने लॉग इन
किया हम लॉगइन हो चुके हैं यहां पे आप देख
सकते हैं नॉर्मल यूजर विनर विनर यहां पे आ
रहा है माय अकाउंट माय अकाउंट आ रहा है
सारी चीजें लॉगइन हो चुकी है अब हम यहां
पे एचटीटीपी हिस्ट्री पे चलते हैं एंड
एचटीटीपी हिस्ट्री पे जब आप जाएंगे तो
यहां पे आपको हिस्ट्री दिखेगी जो जो आपने
वेब पेजेस या जोजो आपने पाथ जो है विजिट
किया है बट यहां पे आपको कुछ पाथ में यहां
पे ग्रीन कलर में हाईलाइट आपको यहां पे
कुछ पाथ यहां पे देख देखने को मिल रहा है
ठीक है अब ये जो ग्रीन कलर में हाईलाइट
हुए हैं ये ड्यू टू द आपका जेडब्ल्यू
एडिटर जो आप यूज़ कर रहे हैं तो इसने
हाईलाइट कर दिया है जो भी आपको कहीं पे
आपको जसन वेब टोकेंस एक्सपोज मिल रहे हैं
कहीं पे देखने को मिल रहे हैं तो वहां पे
ये उन पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट को हाईलाइट कर
देता है तो इससे आप पता लगा सकते हैं यानी
कि अब आपको पता चल रहा है कि अगर आप रियल
टारगेट पे जब इसकी प्रैक्टिस करेंगे या हम
नेक्स्ट क्लास में जब हम लाइव हंटिंग भी
करेंगे तो हमें पता अब आपको समझ में आ गया
कि अब आपको कैसे पता चलेगा कि हमारा यह
रिक्वेस्ट जेडब्ल्यू होल्ड करता है या
कंटेन करता है क्योंकि आपको जितने भी
ऑथेंटिकेशन वाले पेजेस हैं जितने भी लॉगइन
फंक्शनालिस हैंट केशन ऑथराइजेशन पेजेस है
जो भी जिसी किस किसी तरह का भी ऑथेंटिकेशन
पे है आपको उसको विजिट करना है लॉग इन
करना है एंड यहां पे एसीटीपी हिस्ट्री में
आके आपको देखना है कि ग्रीन कलर्ड फिल्टर
जो है कौन-कौन से रिक्वेस्ट पर बन रही है
तो यह आपको समझ में आ रहा है एवरीवन
अंडरस्टैंडिंग दिस थिंग कि अब आपको कैसे
पता
चलेगा बिल्कुल सही बात है यार लाइक्स
लाइक्स कर दो थैंक यू प्रेडेटर वल्फ
लाइक्स के लिए आप सभी लोग बताइए ये आपको
समझ में आ रहा है यहां पे प्लीज एवरी बडी
लेट मी
नो समझ में आ रहा है बहुत लोग है बट
रिप्लाई काफी कम लोग देते हैं यार यह ऐसा
नहीं चलेगा दे दो यहां पर कौन सुपर चैट
किसने किया है सुपर चैट किया है शौर्य
सिंह ने क्या किया इन्होंने योर टीचिंग
मेक्स बग हंटिंग फन एंड सिंपल थैंक यू सौर
धन्यवाद
आपका चलिए जी बताइए बताइए निशा पूछिए
पूछिए डाउट पूछिए तो यहां पे हमारे पास ये
अ आ चुकी है रिक्वेस्ट अब इस रिक्वेस्ट
में आप देख सकते हैं कि माय अकाउंट वाली
जो रिक्वेस्ट है यहां पे विनर वाली वो
रिक्वेस्ट यहां पे आपको दिख रही है यह
आपको दिख रही है रिक्वेस्ट ठीक है तो मैं
इसको थोड़ा सा जो है इसको ऊपर कर देता हूं
यहां पे बिल्को हल्का सा ऐसे कर देता हूं
ठीक है तो यहां पे आपको रिक्वेस्ट दिख रहा
है यहां पे आपको रिस्पांस दिख रहा है राइट
अब
चलिए रिक्वेस्ट एंड रिस्पांस तो दिख गई है
चलिए वेल एंड गुड है अभी सबब रिक्वेस्ट
टैब में जब आप आते हैं यहां पे तो जब आप
देखेंगे ना तो यहां पे कुकीज के अंदर सेशन
के अंदर यहां पे आपको एक टोकन दिख रहा है
एंड दिस टोकन इज एगजैक्टली आपका जसन वेब
टोकेंस क्योंकि जसन वेब टोकेंस को पहचानने
का तरीका है दो डॉट के साथ य आपके तीन
पार्ट में आपको दिखेगा तो यहां पे आपको
दिख रहा होगा पहला पार्ट जो है हमारा यह
पार्ट हो गया
पहला यह यहां से यहां तक का पार्ट हो गया
दूसरा पार्ट आपका यहां से लेके यहां तक का
पेलोड पार्ट जो हो गया वो हो गया एंड
तीसरा पार्ट हमारा ये सिग्नेचर वाली पार्ट
यहां पे हो जाती है ठीक है लेकिन अब
देखिएगा ध्यान से जैसे ही मैं पेलोड पार्ट
को सेलेक्ट करूंगा ना ये वाला पार्ट तो आप
राइट साइड के इंस्पेक्टर में देखिएगा ये
इंस्पेक्टर जो है ना यहां पे ये काम का है
इंस्पेक्टर में देखिएगा मैं यहां पे पेलोड
को यहां से यहां तक ऐसे करके इसको सिलेक्ट
किया मैंने बस पेलोड पार्ट तो आप देख सकते
हैं स्पेक्टर ने ऑटोमेटिक सेलेक्ट कर लिया
टेक्स्ट को एंड डिकोड कर दिया फ्रॉम बेस
64 इसने ऑटोमेटिक चूज किया यहां पे कि ये
बेस 64 की इनकोडिंग थी तो इसको हमने डिकोड
किया डिकोड करने के बाद क्या मिला हमें
कुछ इस तरह का इंफो हमें यहां पे कंट्रोल
सी करके मैं आपको दिखा देता
हूं कुछ इस तरह का इंफो मिला है जहां पे
इज पोर्ट्स फिगर है ये इंफॉर्मेशन है
एक्सपायरी एंड सब जो है यहां पे
सब्सक्राइबर या जो भी बोलेले वो विनर जो
है वो है ठीक है ना तो यहां पे तीन
इंफॉर्मेशन यहां पे आपको मिल जाती है ठीक
है बहुत अच्छी बात है अब हम क्या कर देते
हैं इस पे कुछ काम करेंगे इस पर्टिकुलर
रिक्वेस्ट पे कुछ काम करेंगे क्योंकि यही
हमारा जेसन वेब टोकन होल्ड करता है कंटेन
करता है रिस्पांस में आप जब देखेंगे तो
रिस्पांस में आप देखेंगे तो कुछ नहीं है
यहां पे नॉर्मल सा जो रिस्पांस 200 ओके का
जो रिस्पांस आता है वो रिस्पांस यहां पे आ
चुका है एंड
दैट्ची को थोड़ा सा प्रोसेस करेंगे रिपीटर
पे जाके हम सेंड जब करेंगे यहां पे तो
यहां रिस्पांस हमें आ जाएगा जो रिस्पांस
समय वहां आया हुआ था
दैट्ची है
चलिए अब ये तो आपको समझ में आ गया य कि
हमें यहां पे जसन वेब टोकन मिल चुके हैं
चलिए अब नेक्स्ट प्रोसेस पे चलते हैं यहां
पे नेक्स्ट जो हमारा क्या बोल रहा है ये
यहां पे बोल रहा है ड्यू टू इंप्लीमेंटेशन
फ्लज द सर्वर डज नॉट वेरीफाई द सिग्नेचर
ऑफ एनी जेडब्ल्यू टीज दैट इट रिसीवड स जो
सर्वर है वो वेरीफाई नहीं कर रहा है
सिग्नेचर को वेरीफाई नहीं कर रहा है सिंपल
सा फंड है कोई भी यहां पे सिग्नेचर उसको
वेरीफाई नहीं कर रहा है तो अब यहां पे
क्या रहा टू सॉल्व द लैब मॉडिफाई योर सेशन
टोकन टू गेन एक्सेस टू द एडमिन पैनल ट
एडमिन अब यहां पे स्लैश एडमिन पे ना एक
एडमिन पैनल है तो चलिए एक काम करते हैं
व्हाट अ व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू हमें
एडमिन पैनल को यहां पे हम एक्सेस करने की
कोशिश करते हैं तो यहां पे जो रिक्वेस्ट
है यहां पे ये माय अकाउंट आईडी इ इक्वल टू
विनर पे ना जाके स्ल एडमिन पे जाएगी स्ल
एडमिन पे हमें जाना है यहां पे देखना है
सेंड पे क्लिक करते हैं अब हम सेंड पे
क्लिक करेंगे तो हमें यहां पे इंफॉर्मेशन
मिली है यहां पे रिस्पांस मिला है नीचे की
तरफ स्क्रॉल करेंगे नीचे की तरफ स्क्रॉल
करेंगे स्क्रॉल करेंगे स्क्रॉल करेंगे
स्क्रॉल करेंगे स्क्रॉल करेंगे यहां पे अब
देखो यहां पे जैसे ही हमने स्क्रॉल किया
यहां पे क्या आ रहा है एडमिन इंटरफेस ओनली
अवेलेबल इफ लॉग इन एज एन एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
रेंडर जब करेंगे यहां पे तो आपको रेंडर
होके इसकी अ जो डिटेल डाटा है वो मिलेगी
यहां पे कुछ इस तरीके से ये रेंडर हो रही
है जब हमने स्ल एडमिन को एक्सेस करने की
कोशिश करी तो आ रहा है एडमिन इंटरफेस ओनली
अवेलेबल इफ लॉग इन एज एन एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
अगर आप एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर की तरह लॉग इन है
तभी जाके आपको ये एडमिन इंटरफेस मिलेगा और
आप देखेंगे कि अभी तक हमारा जो यह लैब है
ये अनसोल्वड ही है क्योंकि हमें यहां पे
बेसिकली कार्लोस नाम की यूजर को डिलीट
करना है और उसको तभी डिलीट कर सकते हैं जब
हमारे पास एडमिन इंटरफेस हो तो अब ये कैसे
होगा भैया हम तो एक नॉर्मल यूजर कार्लोस
में लॉगइन है नॉर्मल यूजर में हम सॉरी
विनर में लॉग इन है विनर हमारा हमारा
नॉर्मल यूजर है उसमें हम लॉग इन है तो
हमारा प्रीवियस जो रिक्वेस्ट था वो था ये
था माय अकाउंट आईडी विन इज इक्वल टू विनर
चलिए अब अब जब आप जेडब्ल्यू एडिटर में
आएंगे इस पर्टिकुलर पॉइंट ऑफ टाइम पे तो
यहां देखेंगे कि आपको किसी तरह का कोई
डिटेल यहां पे नहीं दिख रहा है कीज वगैरह
यहां पे कुछ भी यहां पे नहीं दिख रही है
राइट बट आप जो है यहां पे की को जनरेट कर
सकते हैं न्यू सिमेट्री की यहां से जनरेट
कर सकते हैं एंड बेसिकली उससे आप इस
पर्टिकुलर चीज को यहां पे साइन भी कर सकते
हैं यू कैन एगजैक्टली साइन इट अब मैं
फिलहाल के लिए अगेन पेलोड को यहां पे
सेलेक्ट करता हूं मैंने यहां पे पेलोड
यहां पे सिलेक्ट कर लिया ठीक है हमने
पेलोड यहां पे सिलेक्ट कर लिया अब यहां पे
पेलोड का आपको यहां दिख रहा है कि इज
स्पोर्ट्स फिगर एक्सपायरी एंड सब विनर तो
हमें एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर से लॉगइन करना है वी
हैव टू लॉग इन विद एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर सो
व्हाट वी विल डू यहां पे व्हाट वी विल डू
कि हम य यहां पे जो यह यूजर है जेसन वेब
टोकन पर चलते हैं जेसन वेब टोकन वाले इस
वाले पार्ट पे यहां पे चलते हैं एंड यहां
आएंगे तो आप देखेंगे जेडब्ल्यूएस पहला जो
है हेडर जेडब्ल्यूएस जेसन वेब सिग्नेचर
जिसके बारे में मैंने बात की थी जेडल
दोनों क्योंकि ये इंक्रिप्टेड नहीं है तो
ये जेडब्ल्यू ई वाला पोर्शन ये अन हाईलाइट
है इसका कोई मतलब नहीं है जेडब्ल्यू एस ही
हमारा यहां पे यूज में आ रहा है तो यहां
पर आप देख सकते
हैं के आईडी एंड एलजी एल्गोरिथम जो यूज़
हो रही है यहां पे आप ये एल्गोरिदम देख
सकते हैं यहां पे rs256 एल्गोरिदम इज
बीइंग यूज्ड यहां पे जो कि एक सिमेट्री
इंक्रिप्शन है जो कि बेसिकली इसको आप बोल
सकते हैं कि यहां पे पब्लिक एंड प्राइवेट
की दोनों ही यूज़ हो रही है तो यहां पे यह
यूज हो रहा है एंड यहां पे आप देख सकते
हैं पेलोड के अंदर क्या इंफॉर्मेशन है
स्पोर्ट्स फिगर एक्सपायरी सब विनर तो यहां
पे आपका जो है विनर जो है अ यहां पे सब है
तो हमें अब क्या करना है व्हाट वी हैव टू
डू वी हैव टू चचे चेंज
द यूजर नेम यह जो विनर यूजर नेम है इसको
हमें चेंज करना है एंड यहां पर हम करेंगे
ऐड
मिनिस्ट ट्रेटर तो हमने यहां पे किया
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यूजर चेंज किया यहां पे
एंड अब हम इसको यहां पे अप्लाई करेंगे
जैसे हमने अप्लाई किया वी अप्लाइड हियर
यहां पे हमने इसकी वो चेंज कर दी है हमने
इसको अप्लाई कर दिया है अब हम इसे साइन कर
सकते हैं नाउ हियर व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू
डू कि हमें यह नहीं पता है कि इसका क्या
सिग्नेचर है क्या यहां पे साइनिंग की है
कुछ हमें एगजैक्टली मान लो नहीं पता है
लेट्स सपोज वी डोंट नो एनीथिंग राइट तो
हमें यहां पे साइन करना है अ एक सिग्नेचर
से तो यहां पे आप फिलहाल सिग्नेचर देख रहे
होंगे राइट हियर वी कैन सी द सिग्नेचर अब
हम जेडब्ल्यू t एडिटर पे चलते हैं यहां पे
न्यू सिमेट्री की अगर हम यहां पे सिग्नेचर
को साइन करने के लिए न्यू सिमेट्री की
यूज़ करते हैं तो यहां पे आप बेसिकली की
जनरेट करके इसको साइन करने के लिए यूज़
में ले सकते हैं जनरेट करेंगे यहां पे
आपको एक सिग्नेचर मिल जाएगी इस सिग्नेचर
से आप साइन कर सकते हैं तो जो भी आपको
सिग्नेचर चाहिए यह कॉपी किया आपने यहां पे
आप इसको क्रिएट कर सकते हैं बेसिकली न्यू
सिग्नेचर यहां पे करेंगे जनरेट करेंगे
यहां पे हो जाएगी ओके करेंगे यहां पे
सिग्नेचर आपका जनरेट होके आ जाएगा नाउ यू
कैन जस्ट यू कैन जस्ट कॉपी द सिग्नेचर एंड
यू कैन कम टू द रिपीटर एंड यहां पे आप
सिग्नेचर को यूज़ कर सकते हैं जो भी आपका
ये सिग्नेचर है अ इस सिग्नेचर को यहां पे
आप यूज़ करके साइन यूज़ करके साइन कर सकते
हो राइट तो यहां पे जब आप साइन करेंगे
यहां पे तो यहां पे आपका सिग्नेचर जो है
वो पॉपलेट हो जाएगा जो सिग्नेचर आपने
जनरेट किया है एंड यहां पे अब आपको किस
सिग्नेचर से साइन करना है वो सिग्नेचर चूज
करना है तो फिलहाल के लिए यहां पे जो है
वो hs256 सिग्नेचर दी गई है यहां पे जो कि
एक h मैक एए 256 सिग्नेचर होती है तो आप
जो भी सिग्नेचर से साइन करना चाहते हैं वो
सिग्नेचर साइन कर सकते हैं एंड यहां पे
ओके पे क्लिक कर सकते हैं एंड इट विल गेट
साइंड ठीक है तो यहां पे आपका साइन हो
जाएगा फिलहाल के लिए हम यहां पे
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यूजर के लिए और यहां पे जो
है फ्लो क्या है इस पर्टिकुलर वेब
एप्लीकेशन के अंदर में द फ्लज अनवेरीफाइड
सिग्नेचर यहां पे फ्लॉय आपका वो अन
अनवेरीफाइड सिग्नेचर का है वेरीफाई नहीं
किया जाता है सिग्नेचर को तो यहां पे अभी
सिग्नेचर कुछ भी होगा तो यह चलेगा काम
चलेगा लेकिन जब सिग्नेचर अनवेरीफाइड ना हो
रहा हो वेरीफाई होके हो रहा हो उस केसेस
में फिर अगर आपकी सिग्नेचर गलत होती है तो
यहां पे जो आप चेंजेज कर रहे हैं वो चेंज
नहीं होगा वो चेंज जो है वो इनफेक्ट नहीं
होगा ठीक है तो फिलहाल के लिए हम क्योंकि
अनवेरीफाइड सिग्नेचर है तो हम यहां पे अब
देखते हैं रॉ पे चलते हैं यहां पे रॉ पे
चलते हैं तो यहां पे अगेन इफ वी विल चूज
दिस पेलोड वी विल सी दो कि यहां जो सब है
विनर है इसको हमें एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर बनाना
है तो
एडमिनिस ट्रेटर यहां बना दिया अप्लाई
चेंजेज कर दिया यहां पे अप्लाई हो चुकी है
जो भी चेंजेज है अप्लाई हो चुकी है अब
यहां पे हम क्या कर देंगे भैया व्हाट वी
विल डू वी विल गो टू द एडमिन सेक्शन जो
हमारा एडमिन अकाउंट है उस पे जाएंगे तो
यहां पे स्लैश एडमिन कर देते हैं जो पहले
आ रहा था कि आपको एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर से लॉगइन
करना पड़ेगा तो हम यहां पे अब सेंड करते
हैं अब देखते हैं यहां पे जैसे ही सेंड
किया हमने यहां पे अब जैसे ही सेंड करेंगे
यहां पे रॉ फॉर्मेट में चलके देख लेते हैं
रिस्पांस में रिस्पांस में नीचे की तरफ
आएंगे यहां पे नीचे की तरफ आएंगे नीचे की
तरफ आएंगे नीचे की तरफ आएंगे नीचे की तरफ
आएंगे तो अब आप अब आपको दिखेगा तो यहां पे
एडमिन डिलीट यूजर नेम विनर एडमिन डिलीट
यूजर नेम कार्लोस कुछ इस तरह का यहां पे
इंटरफेस आपको देखने को मिल रहा है रेंडर
पे जब आप क्लिक करेंगे तो आप यहां पे
देखेंगे कि ये एडमिन पैनल दिखा रहा है अब
आपको जो पहले एक माय अकाउंट दिखा रहा था
दिस इज नाउ सम काइंड ऑफ एडमिन पैनल जो
हमें यहां पे एडमिन पैनल मिल चुका है तो
वी हैव गॉट द एडमिन पैनल नाउ तो अब जो है
यहां पे आप जो भी चीजें करना चाहते थे वो
आप कर सकते हैं बिकॉज वी आर नाउ लगड इन एज
एडमिन पैनल अब यहां पे जसन वेब टोकेंस में
आप देखेंगे तो यहां पे सब एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
हो चुका है जो पहले क्या था एक नॉर्मल
यूजर हमारा था जो कि विनर था तो अब हम
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर की तरह लॉग इन हो चुके हैं
क्योंकि हमने चेंज किया वहां पे हमने विनर
को एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर बना दिया तो अब हमारे
पास ये इंटरफेस आ चुकी है अब देखिए अब
क्योंकि यहां पे जो हमारे पास अ
पाथ आ चुका है एडमिन डिलीट कार्लोस का तो
हम इसको सिंपली कॉपी कर लेंगे एंड यहां पे
सेम पाथ को हम यहां पे एग्जीक्यूट कर
देंगे एंड यहां पे सेंड करेंगे जैसे ही
सेंड करेंगे यहां पे रिस्पांस देखेंगे 302
फाउंड आया फॉलो करेंगे रीडायरेक्शन को
रीडायरेक्शन फॉलो करेंगे रेंडर देखेंगे तो
यहां देखेंगे कि कांग्रेचुलेशन य सॉल्व द
लैब यूजर्स जो बच गया वो विनर बच गया
क्योंकि कार्लो जो है वो डिलीट हो चुकी है
एंड यहां पे आपका लैब जो है वो सॉल्व हो
चुका है तो यहां पे बेसिकली सिग्नेचर की
हमने कुछ भी डाल दिया था लिटरली वी डिड
नॉट नो व्हाट सिग्नेचर वी हैव टू पुट आउट
देयर तो वेरिफिकेशन प्रॉब्लम था
वेरिफिकेशन इशू था सिग्नेचर का क्योंकि
वहां पे अनवेरीफाइड सिग्नेचर एक्सेप्ट
किया जा रहा था इस वजह से ये चीज काम कर
गई एंड यहां पे आपने एक नॉर्मल यूजर को
एस्केलेट कर दिया प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन हम
इसी को बोलते हैं एक नॉर्मल यूजर को आपने
एक हाई अ एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव यूजर की तरह जो
है वो एस्केलेट कर दिया है बना दिया है
एंड उसके पास वो वाली परमिश आ चुकी है तो
यहां पे हमने ये चीज लैब जो है इसको सॉल्व
कर ली जहां पे हमने जसन वेब टोकन
के किस तरह के फ्लॉक देखा हमने कि उसको
जेसन वेब टोकन ऑथेंटिकेशन बायपास हमने
किया बाया अनवेरीफाइड सिग्नेचर वेरीफाई
नहीं कर रहा उस सिग्नेचर को अगर वेरीफाई
करता तो वहां पर बोल देता कि यह सिग्नेचर
मिसमैच है तो यह पहला हमने पार्ट कंप्लीट
किया यह बताइए सबको समझ में आ गया यह
पार्ट पहले मुझे ये बता दीजिए एवरीवन
जल्दी बताइए फटाफट फटाफट फटाफट फटाफट
फटाफट वड़ा वड़ा
जल्दी हां जल्दी बता दीजिए फटाफट
इतना समझ में आया आप लोगों को यह बता
दीजिए चलिए तो एक और चीज हम देख लेते हैं
इसको हम यहां पे क्लोज कर देते हैं फिलहाल
के लिए इसको वी आर जस्ट क्लोजिंग इट एंड
फॉर नाउ
अ फॉर नाउ व्हाट आई एम गोइंग टू डू बब से
हम इसको हटा के डिसेबल कर लेते हैं
प्रॉक्सी को ठीक है तो हम यहां पे आ चुके
हैं ये आपने देखा पहला एक्सेप्टिंग
आर्बिट्री सिग्नेचर किसी भी तरह का
सिग्नेचर एक्सेप्ट कर लेना है दैट्ची
सिग्नेचर अब मान लो मान लो कि कोई
सिग्नेचर ही ना हो उस केस में तो बायपास
कर लेंगे फिर आप अगर ऐसा कोई मिस कॉन्फिन
हो जाए जेडब्ल्यू टोकेंस के लिए जहां पे
सिग्नेचर ना हो तब भी एक्सेप्ट किया जा
रहा है तो दिस इज अ ह्यूज मिस कन्फेशन इस
तरह के मिस कन्फेशन करो तो खोजना है भैया
मिलते हैं बहुत मिलते हैं अमंग द अदर
थिंग्स जेडब्ल्यू हेडर कंटेंस एंड एलजी
पैरामीटर एल्गोरिदम पैरामीटर जेडब्ल्यूडी
हेडर जो होते हैं उसमें एक एल्गोरिदम
एलजी पैरामीटर होता है दिस टेल्स द सर्वर
वच एल्गोरिदम वाज यूज टू साइन द टोकन कौन
सा एल्गोरिदम उस टोकन को साइन करने के लिए
यूज किया जाए एंड देयर फॉर वच एल्गोरिदम
इट नीड्स टू यूज व्हेन वेरीफाइंग द
सिग्नेचर तो अब यहां पे एल्गोरिथम आप देख
सकते हो कुछ इस तरह से लिखा रहेगा जो भी
है hs256 टाइप जो है जेडटी लिखा रहेगा अब
यहां पे क्या
होगा जेडटी कैन बी साइंड यूजिंग अ रेंज ऑफ
डिफरेंट एल्गोरिथम्स बट कैन आल्सो बी
लेफ्ट अनसाइंड इन दिस केस द एलजी पैरामीटर
इज सेट टू नन अगर हमने मान लो किसी
एल्गोरिदम पैरामीटर को नन कर दिया एंड वो
एक्सेप्ट हो रही है सामने तो वो फिर एक
मिस कॉन्फिन है वहां पे आप उसको अटैक में
ले सकते हैं जेडब्ल्यूडी वहां पे आप जो है
कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर सकते हैं ठीक है
एक्सप्लोइट कर सकते हैं व्हिच इंडिकेट सो
कॉल्ड अनसिक्योर जेडटी उसको अनसिक्योर
जेडब्ल्यू बोलते हैं अगर यहां पे ए एलजी
पैरामीटर नन आपने कर दिया और वो एक्सेप्ट
हो रही है ड्यू टू ऑब् वियस डेंजर ऑफ़ दिस
सर्वर्स यूजुअली रिजेक्ट टोकेंस विथ नो
सिग्नेचर यूजुअली सर्वर रिजेक्ट कर देता
है ऐसे टोकन को जो कि सिग्नेचर लेस होते
हैं हाउ एवर एज दिस काइंड ऑफ़ फिल्टरिंग
रिलाइज ऑन स्ट्रिंग पासिंग यू कैन सम
टाइम्स बायपास दिस फिल्टर्स यूजिंग
क्लासिक ऑफ फस्शन टेक्निक्स सच एज मिक्स्ड
कैपिटेशन और अनएक्सपेक्टेड इनकोडिंग्स ठीक
है तो कुछ इस तरीके के अ चीजों को आप
ट्राई आउट किया जा सकता है कर सकते हैं
ठीक है तो आप या तो ऑफ फ स्केट कर सकते
हैं या किसी तरह का कुछ जो है
अनएक्सपेक्टेड इनकोडिंग्स वगैरह का यूज़ य
करके अलग-अलग तरह के आप ट्राई आउट मार
सकते हैं चलिए हम यहां पे देख सकते हैं
यहां पे एक चीज और है इवन इफ द टोकन इज
अनसाइंड द पेलोड पार्ट मस्ट बी टर्मिनेटेड
विथ अ ट्रेलिंग डॉट यानी कि डॉट से ही
पेलोड जो है वो टर्मिनेट होना चाहिए मैं
आपको बताता हूं एगजैक्टली है क्या ये तो
हम फिलहाल के लिए जो है एक लिंक ओपन कर
लेते हैं एक लैब की एक और लैब देख लेते
हैं फिलहाल के लिए हालांकि लैब्स को आपको
खुद करना है प्रैक्टिस करनी है जितनी
प्रैक्टिस करेंगे उतना आपको दिमाग में
आपके बैठ जाएगा बट क्योंकि लैब्स कर लेने
से क्या होता है कुछ-कुछ अप्रोचेबल जाती
हैं एंड वो अप्रोचेबल टारगेट पे कर सकते
हैं कोई भी लाइफ टारगेट आप ले सकते हैं यू
कैन जस्ट डू इट जेडटी ऑथेंटिकेशन बायपास
वाया फ्लड सिग्नेचर वेरिफिकेशन फ्लड
सिग्नेचर वेरिफिकेशन ठीक है अब यहां पे
सिग्नेचर वेरिफिकेशन अगर कोई फ्लड है उस
केस में क्या हम कर सकते हैं तो इसमें
सिनेरियो क्या बन रहा है दिस लैब यूसेज द
जेडब्ल्यू बेस्ड मैकेनिज्म फॉर हैंडलिंग
सेशंस ठीक
है द सर्वर इज इनसिक्योर कंफिट एक्सेप्ट
अनसाइंड जडब्ल्यू अनसाइंड जडब्ल्यू भी
एक्सेप्ट करते हैं ठीक है
टू सॉल्व द लैब मॉडिफाई र सेशन टोकन टू
गेन एक्सेस टू द एडमिन पैनल एट एडमिन एंड
डिलीट द यूजर कार्लोस सेम आपको यूजर
कार्लोस को डिलीट करनी है लेन इसमें क्या
है कि अनसाइंड टोकन को यहां पर एक्सेप्ट
किया जाता है चलिए तो फिर एक्सेस लैब को
एक्सेस कर लेते हैं य फिलहाल के लिए फटाफट
एंड इसको देखते हैं कि व्हाट वी कैन डू
विद दिस थिंग्स तो यहां फिलहाल के लिए इस
वाले रिपीटर भैया को हम हटा देते हैं यहां
प एंड प्रॉक्सी
से रिमूव इट चलिए तो यहां पर हम लॉगइन कर
लेते हैं पहले तो लॉगइन करने से पहले बॉब
प्रॉक्सी को इनेबल कर देते हैं एंड लेट्स
लॉग इन टू द
अकाउंट सो दैट यहां पे विनर
एंड पीटर लॉग इन कर लेते हैं सेम लॉगइन से
यहां लॉगइन कर लिया हमने विनर विनर नॉर्मल
यूजर आ गया माय अकाउंट सारी चीज आ गई है
एंड यहां देखेंगे तो अगेन हमारे पास
एसटीटीपी हिस्ट्री में हमारी जो ये ग्रीन
कलर की हमारी आ चुकी है रिक्वेस्ट
पैरामीटर्स के साथ यहां पे सेकंड वाली
रिक्वेस्ट जो है हमारी पैरामीटर्स के साथ
200 स्टेटस कोड्स के साथ है तो सबसे
ज्यादा यही हमारे लिए यूज़फुल हो सकता है
तो हम यहां पे आ चुके हैं हमारे पास कुछ
इस तरीके की रिक्वेस्ट जो है वो आ चुकी है
चलिए इस रिक्वेस्ट को फटाफट सेंड टू
रिपीटर पे क्लिक कर देते हैं रिपीटर के
पास लेके चलते हैं एंड इस रिक्वेस्ट को हम
क्या करते हैं इसके रिस्पांस को देख लेते
हैं सेंड करते हैं यहां पे रिस्पांस देख
लेते हैं रिस्पांस कुछ इस तरीके का रॉ
रिस्पांस आपको देखने को मिल जाता है कुछ
इस तरीके का कुछ यहां पे कुछ खास यहां पे
इंफो आती नहीं है रेंडर पे चलते हैं यहां
पे तो रेंडर पे आपको वही सेम माय अकाउंट
वाली जो चीज है वो निकल के आ जाती है चलिए
अब यहां पे
द मेन थिंग इज जेसन वेब टोकन पे जब आप
जाते हैं तो आपको यहां पे जेसन वेब टोकन
दिखेगा एंड दिस वेब टोकन यहां पे के आईडी
दिख रही है यहां पे एल्गोरिदम rs256 यहां
पे दिख रही है यहां पे आपको जो है वो इ स्
पोर्स फगर ् यहां पे एंड सब जो है विनर
आपको यहां पे दिख रहा है अब देखिए यहां पे
हमें क्या करना है व्हाट वी हैव टू डू वी
विल सी हमें यहां पे फ्लॉक है यह फ्लज है
फ्लज कि सिग्नेचर वेरिफिकेशन ही फ्लड है
सिग्नेचर वेरिफिकेशन इज टोटली फ्लड तो
व्हाट वी विल डू कि हम यहां पे पहले रॉ
फॉर्मेट पे यहां पे चलते हैं वी विल गो टू
द रॉ फॉर्मेट यहां पे एंड लेट्स ट्राई टू
एक्सेस द एडमिन एरिया तो हम यहां पे एडमिन
एरिया को यहां पे एक्सेस करते हैं सेंड पे
क्लिक करते हैं एंड लेट्स सी द रिस्पांस
सो यहां रिस्पांस पे आ रहा है 401
अनऑथराइज्ड ये एक अनऑथराइज्ड रिस्पांस
यहां पे आ रहा है एंड यहां पे नीचे की तरफ
आप आएंगे तो यहां पे लिखा रहा है एडमिन
इंटरफेस ओनली अवेलेबल इफ लॉग इन एज एन
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर सेम यहां पे आपको
इंफॉर्मेशन आ रही है तो यहां पे 401
अनऑथराइज्ड अ यहां पर हमें एक स्टेटस मिला
है ठीक है ये तो पता चल गया कि यहां पे
एडमिन यूज़र होना चाहिए तो हम फिर से
प्रीवियस अ वाले हमारे जो है यूआरएल पे आ
जाते हैं जसन वेब टोकन पे यहां पे आप
आएंगे यहां पे तो आप देखेंगे रॉ फॉर्मेट
में जब आएंगे तो हम जब पेलोड को सेलेक्ट
करेंगे यहां से लेके यहां तक तो आप पेलोड
के अंदर एंट्री जो है देख सकते हैं कि
यहां पे विनर है एंड यहां पे स्पोर्ट्स
फिगर करके यहां पे आ आ चुकी है ठीक है
व्हाट वी विल डू नाउ हम जो है जसन वेब
टोकन पे यहां पे जैसे कि हम यहां प आ चुके
हैं यहां पे जेस वेटन पे सो व्हाट वी विल
डू कि हम विनर वाली जो यूजर है इसको हम
बना देते हैं
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर इसमें चेंजेज करते
हैं एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यहां पे हम अप्लाई
करते हैं चेंजेज अप्लाई कर देते हैं यहां
पे ठीक है वी आर वी हैव जस्ट अप्लाइड हियर
यहां पे एंड यहां पे अब चलते हैं र पे
यहां पे एंड हियर इफ वी विल सी
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यहां पे आ चुका है यहां पे
सेंड पे क्लिक करते हैं एंड लेट्स सी सो
इट्स सेंडिंग यहां पे एंड सेंडिंग करेंगे
तो यहां पे हम अगेन क्या करते
हैं
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर अप्लाई अप्लाई हमने किया
यहां पे जैसे आप अप्लाई किया यहां पे सेंड
पे क्लिक करेंगे अब सेंड करेंगे 302 फाउंड
आ रहा है फॉलो रीडायरेक्शन करेंगे यहां पे
200 ओके आ रहा है यहां पे लॉगइन स्ल लॉगइन
करके आ रहा है हम यहां पे सिंपल यहां पे
स्लैश एडमिन पे करेंगे एंड यहां पे सेंड
पे क्लिक करेंगे तो वी विल गो टू द एडमिन
एंड यहां पे जब हम एडमिन की तरफ करके
करेंगे इनफैक्ट जब हम जेसन वेब टोकन पे
जाएंगे एंड यहां देखेंगे कि
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर है हमारा यूजर एंड यहां पे
हमने इस रिक्वेस्ट को भेजा है स्ल एडमिन
पे तब भी हमें एडमिन इंटरफेस ओनली अवेलेबल
फॉर लॉगइन एज एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ही यहां पे
रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा है यानी कि अभी भी हम जो
है लॉगिन नहीं हुए हैं हमें लॉगइन पैनल
नहीं मिला है आप देख पा रहे हो हम एडमिन
से लॉगइन है हम हमने एडमिन यूजर कर दिया
हम यहां पे फिर भी जो है लॉग इन नहीं हो
पा रहे हैं इसका क्या रीजन हो सकता है
मुझे बताइए व्हाट रीजन इट कुड बी
बताइए एवरीवन प्लीज लेट मी नो क्या रीजन
हो सकता है कि हम एडमिन यूजर पे हम एडमिन
वाली पाथ पे भी रिक्वेस्ट कर रहे हैं
एडमिन यूजर भी हैं फिर भी हमें यहां पे जो
एडमिन पैनल मिलना चाहिए था वो नहीं मिला
है सो व्ट कुड बी द
रीजन द रीजन
इज शिवम इ सेइंग की सिग्नेचर
ओके ओके एनी वन एल्स और कोई बोलना चाहते
हैं सिग्नेचर इ नॉट वैलिडेटिंग दिस कैन बी
सॉल्व बा बी रिमूविंग द सिग्नेचर बहुत
बढ़िया बिल्कुल सही आप लोगों ने बोला शिवम
आकर्ष यहां पर जो दिक्कत आ रही है वो आ
रही है इस पर्टिकुलर सिग्नेचर की यह जो
सिग्नेचर आपको यहां पे दिख रहा है यह जो
सिग्नेचर है इस सिग्नेचर की यहां पे
प्रॉब्लम आ रही है दिस इज अ सिग्नेचर
व्हिच इज कॉजिंग इशू सो हमने यहां पे क्या
हम कौन सी चीज तरह का ऑथेंटिकेशन कर रहे
हैं फ्लड सिग्नेचर वेरिफिकेशन यहां पे हम
देख रहे हैं जहां पे सिग्नेचर वेरिफिकेशन
फ्लड है मतलब कि अनसाइंड जेडब्ल्यू इस को
भी यहां पे एक्सेप्ट किया जा रहा है
अनसाइंड जेडब्ल्यू को तो जब यहां पे
जेडब्ल्यू एडिटर में जाएंगे यहां पे तो आप
देख सकते हैं यहां पे एक तो सिग्नेचर जो
हमने ऐड किया था वो चीज थी अब यहां पे
चलके हम क्या कर देते हैं ना सिग्नेचर को
यहां से हम एक बार सिग्नेचर को ही हटा
देते हैं तो हम रॉ पे चलते हैं यहां पे रॉ
वाले फॉर्मेट पे यहां पे हम रॉ वाले
फॉर्मेट में चलेंगे ना तो हम यहां पे पहले
पेलोड वाला ऑप्शन देखो देखो देखो देखो
देखो देखो पेलोड ये रहा पेलोड जब देखोगे
तो यहां डिकोड होके एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर आ रहा
है बट पेलोड के बाद यहां जो डॉट के बाद ये
वाला पोर्शन है ये सिग्नेचर पोर्शन होता
है ये दिस इज सिग्नेचर पोर्शन हम क्या
करेंगे सिग्नेचर को ही डिलीट मार देंगे
हटा देंगे चलो भाई सिग्नेचर हट जाओ अब
हमने सिग्नेचर हटा दिया वी रिमूव द
सिग्नेचर बट ये डॉट हमेशा रहना चाहिए याद
रखिएगा डॉट मत हटा दीजिएगा पेलोड के बाद
जो डॉट है सिग्नेचर के पहले उसको हमेशा
रखना है आपको तो यहां पे हमने डॉट को रखा
है सिग्नेचर पोर्शन हटा दिया जसन वेब टोकन
पे चलते हैं अब वेब टोकन पे जाएंगे तो
यहां देखेंगे आप सिग्नेचर वाली जो पोशन है
ये ब्लैंक हो चुकी है दिस इज कंप्लीट
ब्लैंक पोशन तो हमारा सिग्नेचर हट चुका है
अब हम हटाए हुए सिग्नेचर के बाद जो है
इसको फिर से इस रिक्वेस्ट को भेजेंगे यहां
सेंड करेंगे एंड सेंड करके यहां पे रॉ पे
चलेंगे एंड यहां पे हम देखेंगे कि व्हाट
एल्स वी कैन एक्सेस कुछ हम कुछ कर पा रहे
हैं कि नहीं कर पा रहे हैं इफ यू कैन डू
समथिंग तो हम नीचे की तरफ चलेंगे यहां पे
नीचे की तरफ करेंगे यहां पे आ रहा है फिर
से एडमिन इंटरफेस ओनली अवेलेबल फॉर लगड इन
एज एन एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यूजर तो चलिए भैया
हम पेलोड को फिर से देख लेते हैं यहां पे
पेलोड में क्या एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर नहीं है
क्या व्हाट इज दिस
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर आई थिंक एवरीथिंग इज गुड
यहां पे एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर है यहां
पे बिल्कुल बिल्कुल सही है अब यहां पे
जेडब्ल्यूडी यहां से इसको हटा देते हैं
सिग इस सिग्नेचर को डिलीट मार देते हैं
यहां पे चलते हैं रिपीटर पे सो नाउ
एवरीथिंग इज गुड स्ल एडमिन पे हम यहां पे
स्ल एडमिन पे एक बार सेंड करेंगे
रिक्वेस्ट को हमारे यहां पे हम सेंड
करेंगे तो यहां पे अभी भी ये दिखा रहा है
कि एक अनऑथराइज्ड 401 अनऑथराइज्ड एक्सेस
है यहां पे क्योंकि यहां पे आ रहा है कि
एडमिन इंटरफेस अवेलेबल सिर्फ उसके लिए है
जिसके लिए भैया आपका जेसन वेब टोकन जो है
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर होना चाहिए एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
होना चाहिए इस वजह से तो यहां पर
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ऑलरेडी यहां पर हो चुके
हैं वी आर ऑलरेडी एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर तो एक
बार फिर से क्या करते हैं यहां पर फिर से
लेट्स ट्राई
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर एवरीथिंग इ गुड एंड लेट्स
सेंड दिस तो अब यहां पर यह लॉग इन हो जाना
चाहिए दिस शुड बी लगड इन तो एक बार इस पर
चलते हैं एंड लेट्स
सी व कैन डू
समथिंग यहां पर कुछ भी नहीं आ रहा सेशन
में हम पे आ चुके हैं एंड यहां पे डॉट तो
हमें यहां पे मिल ही चुका है डॉट वी हैव
ट्रेलिंग डॉट से हमने एंड किया है यहां पे
लिखा भी हुआ है आप सिंपली यहां पे आप
देखेंगे कि इवन इफ द टोकन इज अनसाइंड द
पेलोड पार्ट मस्ट बी स्टिल टर्मिनेटेड विथ
अ ट्रेलिंग डॉट तो यहां पे हमने डॉट से
यहां पे इसको एंड कर दिया है तो चलिए अब
यहां पे एक बार इसको चेक आउट कर देते हैं
प्रीवियस जो हमारी लॉगिन है उस पे चलते
हैं प्रीवियस जो हमारी यूआरएल था उसपे एक
बार चल लेते हैं ठीक है तो प्रीवियस लॉगिन
पे हम यूआरएल पे यहां पे चलते हैं एंड इस
यूआरएल पे आते हैं तो यहां पे हमारा
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर है यहां पे सही है
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर की तरह आ रहा है बिल्कुल
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है अब यहां पे जेसन वेब
टोकन पे आते हैं एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर है यहां
पे कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है तो व्हाट वी आर
गोइंग टू डू वी आर गोइंग टू डू इज कि हम
यहां पे यह सिग्नेचर यहां से इस तरीके से
हटा देते हैं यहां पे सिग्नेचर एंड यहां
पे हम पहले इसको रिक्वेस्ट भेज के देखते
हैं व्हाट वी आर तो 302 फाउंड आ रहा है इस
रिक्वेस्ट पे फॉलो डायरेक्शन करते हैं अब
यहां पे 200 ओके आ रहा है चलिए अच्छी बात
है यहां पे एंड यहां पे आप देखेंगे
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर अब हम यहां पे एडमिन जो
सेक् है इसको एक्सेस करने की कोशिश करते
हैं लेट्स सेंड द रिक्वेस्ट 401 अभी
फिलहाल के लिए यहां पे आ रहा है एंड यहां
पे एडमिन इंटरफेस आ रहा है अब यहां पे जसन
वेब टोकन आ रहा है तो यहां पे हमारा
सिग्नेचर जो है वो हट जाना चाहिए तो वी
हैव ऑलरेडी द सिग्नेचर रिमूव्ड एंड यहां
पे आपको यहां पे मिलना चाहिए कि अब आपका
लॉगइन हो सकता है नाउ यू कैन जस्ट
एक्चुअली डिलीट द यूजर कार्लोस कार्लोस को
आप डिलीट कर सकते हैं तो अब यहां पे अगर
देखा जाए तो मैं इसको एक इस तरीके से कर
सकते हैं कि इसको हम यहां से मूव कर देते
हैं यहां पे टारगेट पे प्रॉक्सी पे चल
देते हैं एंड अगेन जो हमारा यह पर्टिकुलर
लॉगइन था ये जो हमारा एटीटीपी मेथड है
एसटीडीपी जो हमारे पास पर्टिकुलर आ रही है
इसको हम डिलीट करके एंड अगेन एक बार ट्राई
आउट कर लेंगे यहां पे जैसे ही हम यहां पे
जाएंगे यहां पे रीलोड करेंगे रीलोड करने
के बाद हमारा ऑथेंटिकेशन जो है यहां पे आ
जाएगा जेडब्ल्यू t अगेन इस पे चलके राइट
क्लिक करके सेंड टू रिपीटर पे क्लिक कर
देते हैं रिपीटर पे आएंगे अगेन हम यहां पे
एक बार सेंड पे क्लिक करके देखेंगे एंड वी
विल सी व्ट व्हाट वी कैन डू तो यहां पे
हमें मिल जा रहा है 200 ओके एंड बाकी जो
चीजें हैं यहां पे देखने को मिल रही है बट
हम एडमिन पैनल को एक्सेस नहीं कर पा रहे
हैं यहां पे क्योंकि यह नॉर्मल अकाउंट है
तो हम क्या करेंगे यहां पे नाउ व्हाट वी
कैन
डू यहां पे चलते हैं एंड यहां पे अब हम
जसन वेब टोकेंस पे चलते हैं यहां पे
जेडब्ल्यूडी एडिटर में कुछ नहीं है यहां
पे यहां पे चलते हैं अब यहां पे हम चेंज
कर देंगे वीी विल बी चेंजिंग द अ
पर्टिकुलर अ यूज़र जो हमारे यूज़र है उसको
चेंज करेंगे तो रॉ पे यहां पे फिलहाल चलते
हैं पेलोड को यहां पे ऐसे सेलेक्ट कर लेते
हैं वी जस्ट सिलेक्टेड द पेलोड यहां पे
हमारा आ चुका है विनर एंड एंड एवरीथिंग तो
वी आर जस्ट गोइंग टू मेक द चेंज
एडम ट्रेटर सो हमने एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर किया
यहां पे अप्लाई किया तो हमारा टोकन
मॉडिफाई हो चुका है वी हैव गट द मॉडिफाइड
टोकन अब जो है यहां पे मॉडिफाइड टोकन जब
हमने कर दिया है तो हम इसके सिग्नेचर को
यहां पर रिमूव कर सकते हैं जस्ट रिमूव द
सिग्नेचर फ्रॉम हियर या तो आप जसन वेब
टोकन पे चलिए यहां से आप सिग्नेचर को
कंट्रोल ए करके यहां से आप सिग्नेचर हटा
दीजिए आप दोनों में से कोई सा भी जो भी
काम करना है वो कर सकते हैं यहां पे हमने
सिग्नेचर हटा दिया अब यहां पे हम यहां पे
इसको साइन कर देते हैं नो साइनिंग की हैव
बीन डेड ठीक है कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
साइनिंग की है ही नहीं तो कहां से होगी तो
यहां पे हमने सिग्नेचर को फिलहाल के लिए
हटा दिया यहां पे रॉ पे चले यहां पे
सिग्नेचर हट चुका है यहां पे अब हम यहां
पे क्या कर देते हैं इसको एडमिन पैनल की
तरह हम एक्सेस कर लेंगे एडमिन पैनल जो
लोकेशन है हमारा उसको एक्सेस करने की
कोशिश करेंगे लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग
नाउ व्हाट व्हेन एवर वी आर जस्ट ट्राइम टू
अगेन इट्स कमिंग एंड जेसन वेब टोकन पे
करके एंड यहां पे क्या करते हैं हम कि
यहां पे सिग्नेचर व्हाट इज
दिस यहां पे हमने ये किया ये दिस इज
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यहां पे एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
किया यहां पे अब हम एक बार इसको साइन करके
देख लेते हैं एक बार हम यहां पे सिग्नेचर
बिल्कुल हटा ही देते हैं सिग्नेचर वी आर
जस्ट रिमूविंग द सिग्नेचर दैट्ची
होके एंड यहां पे आपका एडमिन पैनल बेसिकली
आ जाना चाहिए दिस सम काइंड ऑफ इश्यूज ऑन
गोइंग मस्ट बी
दैट्ची यहां पे हटाना है बेसिकली जो
प्रॉब्लम है यहां पे कि आपका एक अनसाइंड
जेडब्ल्यू t भी एक्सेप्ट ये कर रहा है
यानी कि ये साइंड जेडब्ल्यू t नहीं है दिस
इज अनसाइंड जेडब्ल्यू t जो दैट इज बीइंग
गेटिंग यहां पे एक्सेप्टेड तो अगर हम यहां
पे बैक करते हैं यहां पे सेम उसमें एंड
यहां पे अगर हम सिग्नेचर यहां से हटा देते
हैं कुछ इस तरीके से इस तरीके से कुछ
सिग्नेचर हटा देते हैं जसन वेब टोकन पे
जाते हैं तो यहां पे जब हम एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
करते हैं मान
लो कुछ इस तरीके से एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर कर
देते हैं यहां
पे इसको सेंड करते हैं एंड जब हम इस टोकन
पेलोड को यहां जब हाईलाइट करते हैं तो
यहां पे एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर आ रहा है यहां पे
एंड 302 फाउंड आ रहा है तो फॉलो डायरेक्शन
करेंगे तो यहां पे फॉलो रीडायरेक्शन करने
पे यहां पे आपका लॉगइन पैनल जो है वो
सिंपल लॉगिन पैनल आ जा रहा है सेम आपका
यहां पे जब आप इसको एडमिन की तरह पे यहां
पे आप जब एडमिन की तरह आप इसको एक्सेस
करेंगे तो इट शुड बी कमिंग यहां पे क्या
इट शुड बी कमिंग कि आप एडमिन लॉगइन यहां
पे हो चुके हैं एंड यू आर नाउ गेट गेटिंग
द एडमिन एक्सेस तो यहां पे इस तरीके से ये
चीज आ जाना चाहिए सिंपल सा फंड है अगर
आपको यहां पे सिग्नेचर जो है उसको हटा
देना है तो यहां पे हमने एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
जो है वो डाल के ये चीज को अचीव किया और
ये चीज हम अचीव करेंगे तो यहां पे कुछ
फ्लॉस के कारण कुछ इश्यूज के कारण यहां पे
आपको अभी फिलहाल के लिए ये सॉल्व का वो
नहीं दिखा रहा बट आपको करना यही चीज है
अगर आप सलूशन भी देखेंगे तो आपको सिमिलर
सेम चीज मिल जाएगी ठीक है तो मुझे यह
बताइए कि अभी तक जो भी चीजें बताई गई है
व्हाट एवर थिंग्स यू हैव बीन यहां पर टट
जे डब्ल्यूटीए बारे में जिस तरीके से वह
आपको समझ में आ गया सभी लोग को यह
बताए करेक्ट करेक्ट करेक्ट गट इट गट इट
एवरी बडी प्लीज लेट मी नो प् लेट ठीक है
ये सॉल्व कीजिएगा सॉल्व हो जाएगा आपका ठीक
है ना आप सलूशन को भी देखेंगे सेम चीज
आपको यहां पर दिखेगी कि यहां पे या हां
यहां अच्छा एक चीज हम छोड़ रहे हैं यहां
पे एक चीज हम छोड़ रहे हैं यहां पे एंड
कोई बता सकता है कि हम क्या छोड़ रहे
हैं एक चीज हम छोड़ रहे जिसकी वजह से इशू
आ रहा है जो कोई बता सकता है कि हम क्या
छोड़ रहे हैं वी आर मिसिंग समथिंग जिसकी
वजह से ये इशू आ रहा है हां बिल्कुल सही
बिल्कुल सही बिल्कुल सही बात है शिवम
बिल्कुल सही यहां पर हम जो दिक्कत यहां पे
आ रही है जिसकी वजह से हम यहां पे लॉगइन
नहीं कर पा रहे हैं वो इसलिए क्योंकि हमने
जो यहां पे सिग्नेचर तो हटा दिया है बट
यहां पे हेडर को हम यहां पे बता नहीं पा
रहे हैं कि एल्गोरिदम जो है यहां पे आपको
जो यूज़ हो रहा है उसको नन हमें यहां पे
नन करना होगा हम यहां पे इसको नन नहीं कर
रहे हैं जिसके वजह से ये इशू आ रहा है और
कोई बात नहीं है तो इसको सिंपली आप नन कर
दीजिएगा यहां पे अ एन ओ एन ई नन कर देंगे
यहां पे एंड
दैट्ची है तो यहां पे हम फिलहाल नन नहीं
कर रहे थे फिलहाल के लिए हमने यहां पे अगर
नन कर दिया है देन आप एडमिन एडमिन को
एक्सेस करेंगे जैसे कि यहां से
मैंने इसको कॉपी किया ना यहां
पे ठीक है तो यहां पे य आ रही है
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यहां प सेंड प क्लिक
करेंगे सेंड पे क्लिक करेंगे जैसे ही
रिस्पांस देखेंगे तो आपका रिस्पांस यहां
पे विनर एंड कार्लोस डिलीट का ऑप्शन यहां
पे आ जाएगा रॉ फॉर्मेट में देखेंगे तो आप
यहां देखेंगे नीचे की तरफ का लॉगइन हो
चुके और डिलीट कार्लोस वाला जो पेज है वो
पेज आ चुका है यहां पे इस पेज को आप
सिंपली यहां से कॉपी कर लेंगे एंड अगेन
सेम इस पेज पे जाएंगे एंड यहां पे सेंड
करेंगे तो कार्लोस जो यूजर है वो डिलीट हो
जाएगी और आपका जो लैब है वो बेसिकली
कांग्रेचुलेशन य सॉल्व द लैब ये करके आ
जाएगा तो बेसिकली यहां पे हम एक तरह से
सिग्नेचर जो है जो उसको बिल्कुल हटा दे
रहे हैं नोस नॉट साइन सिग्नेचर वी आर
यूजिंग बेसिकली सिग्नेचर को साइन भी नहीं
किया जा रहा है एंड यहां पे जब हम जसन के
अ जब जेन वेब टोकन के यहां पे हेडर में
जाएंगे तो हेडर में यहां पे एल्गोरिदम को
नन कर दे रहे हैं यहां पे एल्गोरिदम इज
गेटिंग नन तो इसको एक्सेप्ट कि किया जा
रहा है यूजुअली एक्सेप्ट नहीं होना चाहिए
यूजुअली एक्सेप्ट नहीं होना चाहिए फॉर
सिक्योरिटी रीजंस बट यहां पे एक्सेप्ट
किया जा रहा है अनसाइंड जेडब्ल्यू टोकन
जिसकी वजह से जो है हम इस पर्टिकुलर यूजर
को डिलीट कर पा रहे हैं या यूं कहें कि हम
यहां पे लॉगइन कर पा रहे हैं बेसिकली एज
एन एडमिन वी कैन जस्ट सिंपली लॉग इन एंड
आप देख सकते हैं कि यहां पे लैब जो है वो
सॉल्व हो चुकी है अगर यहां पे आप देख सकते
हैं कांग्रेचुलेशन यू सॉल्व द लैब तो कुछ
इस तरीके का जो प्रॉपर तरीका होता है
जेडब्ल्यू ऑथेंटिकेशन बायपास का वो
अलग-अलग तरीके से से कर सकते हैं जो पहला
जो बायपास है हमने किया अनवेरीफाइड
सिग्नेचर से दूसरा जो बायपास किया यहां पे
वो फ्लड सिग्नेचर वेरिफिकेशन की वजह से
किया अब यहां पे बात आती है ब्रूट
फोर्सिंग सीक्रेट कीज ठीक है हम ब्रूट
फोर्स भी कर सकते हैं सीक्रेट कीज को अगर
आप सीक्रेट कीज पे ब्रूट फोर्स करना चाहते
हैं तो आप ब्रूट फोर्स करके सीक्रेट कीज
को भी जो है वो देख सकते हैं या उसको
फाइंड कर सकते हैं सोचो अगर सीक्रेट कीज
अगर हमें मिल जाती है किसी भी रीजन से अगर
हमें पर्टिकुलर इस अ
जेडब्ल्यू t टोकन का अगर सीक्रेट की मिल
गया तो वी कैन डू लिटरली एनीथिंग फिर तो
हम कुछ भी कर लेंगे ना हम लाइक व्हाट एवर
हम सीक्रेट की डालेंगे हम किसी भी तरह के
चेंजेज को करके और उसको साइन कर सकते हैं
और साइंड जेडब्ल्यू को एक्सेप्ट करना है
करना ही करना है सर्वर को करना ही करना है
कोई दिक्कत सिग्नेचर मिसमैच नहीं हुआ तो
उसको साइन को करेगा ही करेगा तो हम
सीक्रेट की कैसे ब्रूट फोर्स करते हैं
लाइव टारगेट पे हम चीजों को फाइंड करने का
अच्छा लाइफ टारगेट का आपको पता चल गया ना
आपको कैसे करना है ये मुझे पहले बता दीजिए
चैट में कोई है अगर तो यहां पे मुझे बता
दीजिए कि आपको यह पता चल गया कि लाइव
टारगेट के लिए हम कैसे पता करेंगे कि
जेडब्ल्यू वहां पर टोकन अवेलेबल है यह
आपको पता चल गया कोई शॉर्ट में बता द
जल्दी से चैट में जल्दी
बताइए यस यू कैन बिकम प्रथम यू कैन
डेफिनेटली बिकम
प्रथम एवरीवन प्लीज जल्दी बता दीजिए लाइफ
टारगेट को हम पता कैसे करेंगे
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल
बिल्कुल
सो बेसिकली व्ट वी कैन डू आपने या व्ट वी
जस्ट लर्न हियर हमें क्या यहां पर य पर
मिला य पर सीखने को वह भी हम देख लेते
हैं सो वट जेडब्ल्यू टी अटैक प हमने पढ़ा
पार्ट वन पार्ट व इसका पार्ट टू भी आएगा
जिसमें और बहुत सारी चीजें है अभी तो वो
भी आपको बताया जाएगा तो हमने पार्ट वन में
यहां पे जेडब्ल्यू अटैक में पढ़ा यहां पे
यहां पर सिंपली आपको क्या करना है सिंपल
सा फंडा है यहां पे इंस्टॉल आपको मतलब
इंस्टॉल जेडब्ल्यू एडिटर जो जेडब्ल्यूडी
जो एडिटर यह वाली जो एडिटर है आपके पास ये
जेडब्ल्यू एडिटर वो आपको इंस्टॉल कर लेना
है तो जे डब्ल्यूटीए जो
है सॉरी यह जेडब्ल्यू है जेडब्ल्यू एडिटर
इंस्टॉल कर लेना है
एडिटर
एक्सटेंशन फ्रॉम बवप स्टोर इन बॉब
सूट ठीक
है उसके बाद ब्राउज
थ्रू थ्रू ऑल द
ऑथेंटिकेशन
या
ऑथराइजेशन सेक्शंस ऑफ वेबसाइट्स
टारगेट एंड एंड कीप
लुकिंग कीप लुकिंग
द एचटीटीपी
हिस्ट्री
टैब इन
बॉब फॉर ग्रीन कलराइज्ड
रिक्वेस्ट जेडब्ल्यू टी टोकेंस ठीक है तो
आपको यह देखना है उसके बाद यहां पे
जेडब्ल्यू
टोकन प्ले विथ द टोकेंस
टू
बाईपास एनी
ऑथेंटिकेशन या ऑथराइजेशन ठीक है उसके बाद
आपको उसके साथ खेलना है टोकन के साथ कि
भैया किसी तरह का को ऑथेंटिकेशन है या
किसी तरह का ऑथराइजेशन है उसको आप यहां पे
देख सकते हैं तो तीन पार्ट बेसिकली थ्री
पार्ट्स में आपका यह पूरा का पूरा
सिनेरियो है यहां पे पहले पार्ट में आपका
जेडटी एडिटर एक्सटेंशन बवप स्टोर में बब
सूट में इंस्टॉल करना है लेटेस्ट वर्जन बब
सूट होना चाहिए सपोर्ट तभी करेगा दूसरा आप
कम्युनिटी एडिशन बब सूट यूज़ कर सकते हैं
प्रो की जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी इस केस में
दूसरा जो है ब्राउज थ्रू आप अपने सिस्टम
में दोनों ही चीजों को रखिए आप दोनों ही
चीजों को यूज़ कर सकते हैं बॉब सूट का
कम्युनिटी एडिशन तो ऑलवेज इंस्टॉल करके
रखिए जहां-जहां कम्युनिटी एडिशन से काम चल
जा रहा है आप उसको यूज़ कीजिए अदर वाइज
लेटेस्ट वर्जन आप उसमें यूज़ कर पाएंगे
ंगे जहां फिर आपको प्रो की जरूरत पड़ेगी
आप प्रो को यूज़ कर लीजिए ब्राउज थ्रू ऑल
द ऑथेंटिकेशन ऑथराइजेशन सेक्शंस या एंड
पॉइंट्स आप इसको बोल सकते हैं एंड पॉइंट्स
तो ये एंड पॉइंट्स नॉर्मल एंड पॉइंट्स हो
सकते हैं एपीआई एंड पॉइंट्स हो सकते हैं
कोई सा भी एंड पॉइंट जहां पे आपको लगता है
ऑथराइजेशन या ऑथेंटिकेशन प्रोसेस है एक अ
प्रोसेस एलिमेंट है वेबसाइट के ऊपर में तो
उसको आप विजिट कीजिए ठीक है सिंपली आपको
विजिट करना है लॉग इन करना है विजिट करना
है लॉगइन करना है ऑथराइज करना है अपने
आपको एक नॉर्मल सा आप आप एज ए अटैकर
रहेंगे एंड फिर आपको एचटीटीपी हिस्ट्री
टैब जो है आपका इस बॉब सूट के अंदर में
प्रॉक्सी के अंदर में जाएंगे एचटीटीपी
हिस्ट्री तो आप इसको देखते रहिए कि यहां
पे कोई ग्रीन कलर का किसी कोई रिक्वेस्ट
जो है कलराइज रिक्वेस्ट आपको मिल रही है
क्या जो कि जेसन वेब टोकन हो सकती है आपको
उसके बाद टोकन के साथ खेलिए उसको बायपास
करने की कोशिश कीजिए देखिए कि किस तरह का
बायपास आप वहां पे अप्लाई बेसिकली कर सकते
हैं किस तरह का बायपास अप्लाई करके फिर आप
उसको एग्जीक्यूट या एक्सप्लोइट कर सकते
हैं तो ये तीन तरीके तो ये तो हमने तीन
तरीका देखा जो कि हमने पार्ट वन में आज
कवर कि किया है अब पार्ट टू में जब हम इस
पर्टिकुलर वनबिल का देखेंगे तो हम लाइव
हंटिंग बेसिकली कर रहे होते हैं एक टारगेट
पे हम लाइव हंटिंग करेंगे टारगेट पे चूज
करेंगे लाइव हंट करने की कोशिश करेंगे एंड
देखेंगे कि इफ वी कैन फाइंड एक्चुअली
समथिंग जेडब्ल्यू या टोकन ऐसा कुछ हमें
मिल जा रहा है तो तो ये हम नेक्स्ट क्लास
में भी देखेंगे एंड ऊपर से हमें और जो
डिटेल्स है यहां पे ब्रूट फोर्सिंग से
रिगार्डिंग ब्रूट फोर्सिंग करना या गेसिंग
करना या अदर थिंग्स जो जेडब्ल्यू टोकन के
रिगार्डिंग है वो भी हम नेक्स्ट क्लास में
देखेंगे तो नेक्स्ट क्लास जो है और भी
इंटरेस्टिंग होगी एंड और भी मजेदार होने
वाली है जो आपको देखना है एंड उस क्लास को
भी मिस नहीं करना है याद रखिएगा मिस मत
कीजिएगा बहुत कुछ अभी इसमें बचा हुआ है वो
हम करेंगे ठीक है दूसरी चीज यहां पे कि अ
वट इ थैंक यू फॉर मोटिवेटिवेशनल
ठीक
है बिल्कुल देखिए कोई दिक्कत नहीं है कोई
दिक्कत नहीं
है अ फ्रॉम लिस्टिंग यू आई विल बी फॉलो यू
ब्लाइंड लव यू रियली लाइक योर वीडियो थैंक
यू प्रथम थैंक यू ब्रदर चलिए तो अब यहां
पे ना हम आने वाले टाइम में व्हाट वी आर
एक्सपेक्टिंग वी आर आल्सो एक्सपेक्टिंग
लाइव हंटिंग क्लासेस तो अगर आप एग्री करते
हैं इस चीज से या अगर आप चाहते हैं कि ऐसी
क्लासेस हो तो प्लीज वोट कीजिए प्लीज
बताइए अ एंड
whatsapp-web साथ किस तरीके की चीजें आती
है तो लाइव जब हंटिंग करेंगे तो उसमें
सारी वल्नरेबल कीज को हम कवर अप करेंगे जो
वल्नरेबल जिस पे हम पहले जाना चाहे जो हम
हमारा अप्रोच होगा या जो भी मेथड होंगी उन
सब को हम ट्राई आउट करेंगे राइट तो वी विल
बी ट्राइंडर बी हंटिंग ठीक है
चलिए नेक्स्ट क्लास जल्दी आएगी टेंशन अब
नहीं लेना भैया आपको नेक्स्ट क्लासेस जो
हैं अब फ्रीक्वेंसी
भी आएंगे सीटीएफ हम स्टार्ट करेंगे तो हम
सीटीएफ भी लाइव करेंगे तो उसको भी हम
देखेंगे ठीक है तो वी विल डू एवरीथिंग ओके
चलिए आई होप कि आप सबको समझ में आ चुका
होगा हर एक चीज एंड क्लियर होगा सो अब जो
है आप अपने दोस्तों के बीच इस वीडियो को
शेयर कीजिए इस क्लास के बाद एंड होने के
बाद उनको बताइए आप जहां ग्रुप्स में
whatsapp2 सेंचुरी जो है क्रिकेट में गा
जाती है हम यहां पर बग बांटी की सीरीज में
लगा चुके हैं जल्दी य सेंचुरी भी हो जाएगी
अपनी एंड इस सीरीज को धुर्र लोग भी हैं जो
देखते हैं कांसेप्ट क्लियर करने के लिए
लिटरली जो बग बाउंट हंटिंग के धुर्र लोग
भी हैं काफी अच्छे लेवल पर भी है वह भी
कांसेप्ट के लिए देखते हैं सो ट्स इट
गाइस
ओके चलिए तो
चलिए आज के सेशन को हम यहीं पर एंड करते
हैं आर जस्ट एंडिंग दिस सेशन थैंक यू सो
मच एवरीबॉडी
सून बहुत जल्दी धन्यवाद एंड हैव अ गुड
नाइट सभी को गुड नाइट आप लोग शेयर कर
दीजिए एंड लाइक ठोकते हुए चले जाइएगा लाइक
ठोकते हुए जाइएगा याद
रखिए बिल्कुल बिल्कुल चलिए अच्छी बात
है चलिए ओके बाय टाटा